- boom alright well I thank you very
much for doing this man I really
appreciate it I've been absorbing your
information and listening to you talk
for quite a while now so it's it's great
to actually meet you thanks for having
me my pleasure my pleasure you are one
of the rare guys that is you're a big
investor you are you're deep in the tech
world but yet you seem to have a very
balanced perspective in terms of how to
live life as opposed to not just be
entirely focused on success and
financial success and tech investing but
rather how to live your life in a happy
way that's a it's a it's not balanced
yeah you know I think the reason why
people like hearing me is because like
if it's like if you go to a circus and
you see a bear right that's kind of
interesting but not that much if you see
a unicycle that's interesting but you
see a bear on a unicycle that's really
interesting right so when you combine
things you're not supposed to combine
yeah I get interested it's a Bruce Lee
right striking thoughts philosophy plus
martial arts mmm and I think it's
because at some level all humans are
broad we're all multivariate but we get
summarized in pithy ways in our lives
and at some deep level we know that's
not true right
every human basically is capable of
every experience and every thought you
know your UFC comedian commentator
podcaster but you're also more than that
you're also father lover you know
thinker etc so I like the model of life
that the ancients had the Greeks the
Romans right where you would start out
and when you're young you're just like
going to school then you're going to war
then you're running a business then
you're supposed to serve in the Senate
or the government then you become a
philosopher this sort of this arc to
life where you try your hand at
everything and as one of my friends says
specialization is for insects hmm so
everyone should just be able to do
everything and so I don't believe in
this model anymore of trying to focus
your life down on one thing you've got
one life just do everything you're gonna
do I couldn't agree more
and I I think
sometimes people find certain success in
whatever the endeavor is and then they
think that that is their niche and they
stick with it and they never change and
they did almost out of fear well it's
hard because there's a the analogy
around mountain climbing like if you
find a mountain and you start climbing
you spend your whole life climbing it
and you get say 2/3 of the way and then
you see the peak is like way up there
but you're 2/3 of the way up you're
still really high up but now to go the
rest of the way you're gonna have to go
back down to the bottom and look for
another path nobody wants to do that
people don't want to start over and it's
the nature of later in life that you
just don't at the time so it's very
painful to go back down and look for a
new path but that may be the best thing
to do and that's why when you look at
the greatest artists and creators they
have this ability to start over that
nobody else does like Elon will you know
be called an idiot and start over
doing something brand new that he
supposedly is not qualified for or when
Madonna or Paul Simon are you to come
out a new album their existing fans
usually hate it because they've adopted
a completely new style that they've
learned somewhere else a lot of times
they'll just miss completely so you have
to be willing to be a fool and kind of
have that beginner's mind and go back to
the beginning to start over if you're
not doing that you're just getting older
yeah I mean I don't even know if it's
willing to be a fool it's just to me
that the most exciting thing is to try
to get better at something to learn that
thinks I mean it's really exciting when
you just have incremental progress and
something that you're completely new to
yeah I live for the aha moment that
moment when you connect two things
together that but you hadn't connected
together more and it fits nicely and
solidly and it kind of helps form a
steel framework of understanding in your
mind that you can then hang other ideas
off of that's what I live for
yeah it's that curiosity fulfilled
that's what little children do to you
know my little son is always asking why
why why why why and I always try to
answer him and half the times I realized
actually I don't really understand why I
just have a memorised answer for you but
that's not really understanding yeah
those are weird conversations right when
you're you're talking your kids and you
say look the reality is I don't know a
lot of things yes
I've just memorized a lot of yeah and
there's certain things that you just
can't know yeah you realize that you
know you have you have answers for a few
things that you've thought through then
you sort of have cover up slinging like
trapdoors like don't go here this is
just the cover up I don't really know
the answer to what the irony of life is
or how we got here yes and then you've
got a whole bunch of memorized stuff
because a lot of your a lot of
intelligence these days just the
external brain pack of civilization I
know it's out there I know the answers
are out there know how to look them up
and I've memorized some of them and they
I kind of understand how money works in
the federal reserve prints it and what
this government thing is but not really
right so not good enough to teach it in
the university yeah yeah that I think
people do that with almost everything in
life these days in terms of we have like
a one-page a one sheet like a brief
summary of what and the explanation for
what this very complex subject might be
healed er right yeah don't give me the
lecture give me the book don't give me
the book give me the blog don't give me
the blog post give me the tweet don't
give me the tweet I just I already know
ya got really fascinated by the way you
read because I thought there was
something wrong with me by doing that
but you you don't really just read a
book to completion you read and then you
pick something else up and you just kind
of go based on your whims whatever
you're interested in well I was raised
by my I was raised by a single mom in
New York and she used the local library
as a daycare center because it was a
very tough neighborhood and so she would
basically say when you get back from
school go straight to the library and
don't come out until I pick you up late
at night so I used to basically live in
the library and I read everything I read
every magazine I read every pictograph I
read every book or every map I just ran
out of stuff to read I just read
everything so I got over this idea of
that reading a large number of books or
reading a book to completion
as a vanity metric because really when
people are putting up photos on Twitter
Instagram of look at my pile of books
that I'm reading it's it's a show-off
thing it's a signaling yeah and the
reality is I would rather read the best
hundred books over and over again until
I absorb them rather than read all the
books right yeah because your brain has
finite information
and if a finite space you get enough
advice it all cancels to zero there's a
lot of nonsense in books out there too
so I don't read anymore to complete
books I read to satisfy my genuine
intellectual curiosity and it can be
anything it could be nonsense it could
be history could be fiction it could be
science it could be sci-fi these days
it's mostly sci-fi philosophy science
because that's just what I'm interested
in but I will read for understanding so
a really good book I will flip through I
won't actually read it consecutive in
order and I won't even just leave and
finish it I'm looking for ideas things
that I don't understand and when I find
something really interesting I'll
reflect on it I'll research it and then
when I'm bored of it I'll drop it or
I'll flip to another book thanks to
electronic books I've got 50 70 books
open at any time in my Kindle or iBooks
and I'm just bouncing around between
them it's also a little bit of a defense
mechanism to how in modern society we
get too much information too quickly and
so our attention spans are very low so
you get Twitter you get Instagram you
get Facebook you just used to be
bombarded with information so you can
take that too you can view that as a
negative and be like I have no attention
span or you could view that as a
positive I multitask really well and I
can dig really fast I can if I find a
thread that's interesting I can follow
through five social networks through the
web through the libraries through the
books and I can really get to the bottom
of this thing very quickly it's like the
Library of Alexandria that I can
research in my disposal so I no longer
track books read or even care about
books read it's about understanding
concepts yeah you brought up two awesome
points first of all the the social media
aspect of books and basically anything
it's like it's such a weird way to
display your life because it's you know
you're displaying that the best aspects
of your life and some sort of a glass
case you know it's it's an unrealistic
version of your life that you cultivate
and you curate and I'm I'm as guilty of
that as anybody everybody's guilty I'm
guilty of it too yeah I mean I posed
with my dog every time I run yeah we're
always signaling yeah it's like rather
than really looking at yourself you're
looking at how other
people look at you like this one remove
mental image and it's kind of a disease
because social media is making
celebrities of all of us and celebrities
and most miserable people in the world
right because they're this strong self
image that gets built up it gets built
up by compliments every time somebody
pays you and me a compliment and we're
like oh well thank you right then that
builds up an image of who we are and
then one idiot comes along 1 out of 10
one out of a hundred and they can easily
tear it down hmm because it doesn't take
many insults to cancel out a lot of
compliments and now you're carrying
around this big weighty self-image and
it's just very easy to be attacked and
because you're you're famous or you're
well-known people want to attack you so
being a celebrity is no good it's
actually a problem like one of my tweets
is and these are all reminders to myself
is you want to be rich and anonymous not
poor and famous hmm there's benefits to
it of course but we wouldn't do it it
has unusual problems that you don't get
trained for and you really will not
understand unless you experience it you
know it goes having this conversation
with my wife we're talking about people
that just come up to you and they don't
care what you're doing they don't care
if I'm with my daughter if I'm holding
her if I'm feeding her for you know
we're in the middle of an intense
conversation she's crying she could be
crying and some bro will come over and
just immediately have to take a picture
doesn't care his needs supersede the
daughter and my wife was saying I that
before she knew me she used to think
that that's just part of the price of
being famous that people people like you
that's just part of the price to be
famous and now when it interrupts her
life and you know interrupts the
children and interrupts friends and you
know she now she's like this is annoying
like this is not this is not healthy
this is not a smart way to interact with
people and that people have this weird
challenge this weird thing that if
you're if you become famous there's this
weird challenge where people just want
to come to you especially today because
if they get a photo of you then that
boosts their social media profile like
hey I'm sitting here with navall look at
that smile
anonymity is a privilege on the other
hand is self-inflicted I mean we've
gotten ourselves yeah I don't think we
knew what it was though we did but we
carry on yeah it tells us you're getting
something out of it so you know there
are times when some will approach me in
public and I'm a little resentful and
there are other times they're just like
actually I'm really grateful that you
know I work for this I got this right
this is the payoff just embrace that
smile grin and bear it means you have a
different sort of celebrity to write
you're a you're a hero amongst investors
and amongst I mean you've just made hero
among young male geeks which is some of
my favorite people right but that's not
the kind of celebrity I think most
people set out to get especially most
guys want the cute females yeah yeah I
look at my brief little YouTube clips I
have a tiny little podcast going now
and it's like 95% male 18 to 35 yeah we
what do we what is the numbers yeah it's
in the 90s yeah you you do that one you
do that one very small podcast where you
just have small like three or four
minute clips yeah so what it was I did a
tweet storm called how to get rich
without getting lucky and it got pretty
popular in Twitter and it's really about
wealth creation I just used a clique
baby title and it's trying to basically
lay out timeless principles of wealth
creation that if you absorb them you
become the kind of person who can create
wealth create business make money and my
theory behind that is like there are
three things
everybody wants there's actually more
than three but let's say let's just
start with three the three basics
everybody wants to be wealthy everybody
wants to be happy and everybody wants to
be fit and I know there's a lot of which
you signal that goes on like we don't
want money and you know I don't care
about being happy and happiness is for
stupid people but let's face it like you
want to be rich and happy and healthy
that's the trifecta now of course you
also want to internally calm state of
mind you want a loving household so
there are other things that come into it
but those three I think they can
actually be taught right and a fitness
I'm not going to teach there are a lot
of people who you've had on here
including yourself who know heck of a
lot more about fitness and health than I
do but I was born poor and miserable
and I'm now pretty well off and I'm very
happy and I don't and I worked at those
and so I've learned a few things there
are some principles and so I try to lay
them out but in a timeless manner where
you can kind of figure it out yourself
because at the end of the day I can't
really teach anything I can only inspire
you and maybe give you a few hooks so
you can remember things when they happen
or put it put a name to them so this
podcast actually ended up explaining
this tweet storm so there's a tweet
storm with like 36 38 tweets got very
famous got translated dozens of
languages and these were principles that
I came up with for myself when I was
really young around 13 14 and I've been
carrying them in my head for 30 years
and I've been sort of living them and
over time I just realized like sadly or
fortunately the thing that I got really
good at was looking at businesses and
figuring out the point of maximum
leverage to actually create wealth and
capture some of that and do it in a very
long-term kind of way not let the you
know banker hmm crash the economy yeah
all that kind of way but you know build
businesses and help people and provide
value kind of way especially when
applied to modern technology and
leverage in this age of infinite
leverage that we live in so the podcast
is just explaining each tweet so these
are little three four five minutes
snippets I don't like to say the same
thing twice I don't like to explain in
detail I just I feel like if you have
something original and interesting to
say should say it otherwise it's
probably been said better so that
podcast tries to be information dense it
tries to be very concise it tries to be
high-impact it tries to be timeless and
it has all the information I think you
need the principles that if you absorb
these and you work hard over ten years
you get what you want so I've got the
one on wealth creation I'm going to
attempt to do one on happiness is a big
word but you know happiness and inner
peace and calm and all that because what
you want is you don't want to be the guy
who succeeds in life while being high
strung high stress and unhappy and
leaving a trail of emotional wreckage
with you and your loved ones which is
more common than not because you got a
focus and that's very hard to be great
at everything you want to be the guy or
the gal who
there calmly you know quietly without
struggle now you want to be the person
who's the when there's a crisis going on
you want to be the comest coolest
cucumber in the room who still also
figures out the correct answer hmm if
you can be you were one of the things
that you were saying is that you feel
like happiness is something that you can
learn and then you can teach yourself to
be happy even just by adopting the
mindset that you are a happy person and
proclaiming that to your friends and so
you've sort of developed a social
contract I'm a happy person and though I
have to live up to that yeah I've got
hundreds of techniques but them how to
develop that one oh well there's just a
there's social consistency right humans
have a need to be highly consistent with
their past
pronouncements so the way I started my
first tech company was I was in a in
working inside a larger organization and
I told everybody that I was gonna go
start a company it was like I hate this
place I'm gonna do my own thing I'm
gonna be successful entrepreneur six
months past nine months pass then people
start getting you're still here I
thought you were gonna go start a
company mmm right that was the
implication so we kind of know this
right social contracts are very powerful
like if you want to give up drinking
right and you're not serious about it
you'll say I'm gonna cut back I'm gonna
have only one drink a night I'm gonna
only drink on weekends you tell yourself
but if you're serious you announced it
on Facebook you'll tell all your friends
you'll tell your wife you'll say I'm
done drinking I'm throwing everything
out of the house you'll never see me
drink again when you say that you know
you're serious so I think a lot of these
are choices that we make and happiness
is just one of those choices and this is
unpopular to say because there are
people who are actually depressed you
know chemically or what-have-you and
there are people who don't believe that
it's possible because then it creates a
responsibility on them it says oh now if
I'm you're saying if I'm not happy
that's my fault
I'm not saying that but I'm saying that
just like fitness can be a choice health
can be a choice nutrition can be a
choice working hard and making money can
be a choice happiness is also a choice
if you're so smart how come you aren't
happy how come you haven't figured that
out that's my challenge to all the
people who think they're so smart and so
capable
if you
smart and capable why can't you change
this hmm there are a bunch of people
though that actually take pleasure and
being miserable
there's something about the pursuit of
excellence and of success that
supersedes all other pursuits that in in
their eyes it is it is that the peak the
pinnacle the most important thing it's
not a trade-off hmm I would argue that
it not when I say happy happy is one of
those words that means of zillion
different things right it's like love
right what does that mean cheese yeah I
find it a little bit more tightly right
so let's go back to desire right this is
old old Buddhist wisdom I'm not saying
anything original but desire to me is a
contract that you make with yourself to
be unhappy until you get what you want
MA and I keep that in front of mine so
when I'm unhappy about something I look
for what is the underlying desire that I
have that's not being fulfilled it's
okay to have desires and you're a
biological creature can you put on this
earth you have to do something you have
to have desires you have a mission but
don't have too many don't pick them up
unconsciously don't pick them up
randomly don't have thousands of them my
coffee is too cold doesn't taste quite
right I'm not sitting perfectly oh I
wish it would warmer you know my dog
you know pooped in the lawn I didn't
like that whatever it is pick your one
overwhelming desire it's okay to suffer
over that one but on all the others do
you want to let them go so you can be
calm and peaceful and relaxed and then
you'll perform a better job most people
when you're unhappy like a depressed
person it's not that they have very
clear calm mind they're too busy in
their mind the sense of self is too
strong they're sitting indoors all the
time their minds working working working
they're thinking too much well if you
want to be a high-performance athlete
how good of an athlete are you gonna be
if you're always having epileptic
seizures if you're always like twitching
and running around and like jumping in
your your your limbs are flailing out of
control the same way if you want to be
effective in business you need a clear
calm cool collected mind Warren Buffett
plays bridge all day long and goes for
walks in the Sun he doesn't sit around
like constantly loading his brain with
non-stop information and and and getting
worked up about every little thing
we live in an age of infinite leverage
what I mean by that is that your actions
can be multiplied a thousandfold either
by broadcasting at a podcast or by
investing capital or by having people
work for you or by writing code so
because of that the impacts of good
decision-making are much higher than
they used to be because now you can
influence thousands or millions of
people through your decisions or your
code so a clear mind leads to better
judgment leads to better outcome so a
happy calm peaceful person will make
better decisions and have better
outcomes so if you want to operate at
peak performance you have to learn how
to tame your mind just like you have to
learn how to tame your body I love what
you're saying Warren Buffett might not
be the best example because he drinks
like I think six coca-cola's a day and
he eats mostly McDonald's and he's still
alive somehow something shows you that
low stress is more like [ __ ] like how
old is he and he's a fairly old man with
Charlie Munger's I think in his 90s
right yeah I made it really far I wonder
what Warren's doing you know I mean just
he's got it no that's bad for him but if
Harold doesn't care he doesn't care I
think he's just a little stress yes is
the big right so he just enjoys that
coca-cola and that's brought maybe there
is a trade-off right maybe him enjoying
that junk food and that Coke just ah
that the pleasing of the mind is maybe
better than him just eating wheatgrass
shots and yeah and beaver salads and
just being yeah just super
worked up about everything it's like if
you need your glass of red wine and
destress and calm down that's probably
better than you flying off the rails
right right and I think that that's
applicable not just in business but in
probably any pursuit and I like what
you're saying about allow that one thing
to be your obsession but everything else
just you know learn how to learn how to
let things go pick your battles and we
like to think that we like to view the
world as linear which is I'm gonna put
in eight hours of work I'm gonna get
back eight hours of output right it
doesn't work that way
a guy running the corner grocery store
is working just as hard or harder than
you and me how much output is he getting
what you do who you do with how you do
it wait
more important than how hard you work
writing outputs are nonlinear based on
the quality of the work that you put in
the right way that work is like a lion
you don't you and I are not like cows
we're not meant to graze all day right
we're meant to hunt like lions we're
closer to carnivores in our um nervous
development than we are to herbivores we
don't tell vegans oh yeah sorry
look I wish all that stuff worked I
don't want to eat meat this future
generation will look back at us as worse
than slavers you know because the
Holocaust were committing with the
animals but they all have artificial
meats that taste in our healthier is
better than the real thing
so allegedly allegedly but so ism as a
modern knowledge worker athlete as an
intellectual athlete you want to
function like an athlete which means you
train hard then you sprint then you rest
then you reassessed you get your
feedback loop then you train some more
then you sprint again then you rest
then you reassess this idea that you're
gonna have linear output just by
cranking every day at the same amount of
time saying that that's that's machines
you know machines should be working 9:00
to 5:00 humans are not meant work 9:00
are not meant to work 9:00 to 5:00 no I
agree wholeheartedly but that's it for
people that are working for someone
there's not really that option so that's
unfortunately the the rub right that is
kind of where my tweet storm starts
which is first of all the first thing if
you're gonna make money is that you're
not gonna get rich renting at your time
even lawyers and doctors were charging
three four five hundred dollars an hour
they're not getting rich because their
lifestyle slowly ramping up along with
your income and they're not saving
enough they just don't have that bit of
retire so the first thing you have to do
is you have to own a piece of a business
you need to have equity either it's an
owner and investor shareholder or a
brand that you're building that accrues
to you to gain your financial freedom
yeah and I was really fascinated by
another thing that you were bringing up
about working for yourself that you feel
in the future whether it's fifty or
hundred years from now virtually
everyone is going to be working for
themselves and I believe the way you put
it is that the information age is going
to reverse the Industrial Age yeah if
you go back to hunter-gatherer
times how we evolved we basically work
for ourselves we communicated and
cooperated within tribes but each hunter
each gatherer stood on their own and
then combine their resources with a
family unit
but there was no boss hierarchy honey
higher you know you're like the third
middle manager down in the farming Age
we became a little bit more hierarchical
as we had to run farms but even those
were still mostly family farms it's
industrial work with factories that sort
of created this model of thousands of
people working together on one thing and
having bosses and schedules and times to
show up the reality is if you have to go
I don't care how rich you are I don't
care whether you're like a top Wall
Street banker if you have to go if
somebody has to tell you if somebody can
tell you when to be at work and what to
wear and how to behave you're not a free
person you're not actually rich so we're
in this model now where we think it's
all about employment and jobs and
intrinsic in that is that I have to work
for somebody else but the information
age is breaking that down so Ronald
Coase is an economist who has this coast
theorem a very famous theorem but it
basically just talks about why is a
company the size that it is why is a
company one person instead of ten people
instead of a hundred instead of a
thousand and it has to do with the
internal transaction costs which is the
external transaction costs let's say I
want to do something let's say I'm
building a house and I need someone to
come in and provide the lumber I'm a
developer right do I want that to be
part of my company or do I want that to
be an external provider a lot of it just
depends on how hard it is to do that
transaction with someone externally
versus internally if it's too hard to
keep doing the contract every time
externally I'll bring that in-house if
it's easy to do externally and it's a
one-off kind of thing I'd rather keep it
out of the house well information
technology is making it easy and easier
to do these transactions externally it's
becoming much easier to communicate with
people gig economy I can send you small
amounts of money I can hire you through
an app I can rate you afterwards so
we're seeing an atomization of the firm
we're seeing the optimal size the firm's
shrinking it's most obvious in Silicon
Valley tons and tons of startups
constantly coming up and shaving off
little pieces of businesses from large
companies and turning them into huge
markets so what looked like
a small little vacation rental market on
Craigslist is now suddenly blown up into
Airbnb one example that's one example
but what I think we're going to see is
whether it's 10 20 50 hundred years from
now high-quality work will be available
when I talk about driving an uber we're
talking about super high quality work
will be available in a gig fashion where
you'll wake up in the morning your phone
will buzz and you'll have five different
jobs from people who work with you in
the past or have been referred to you
it's kind of like how Hollywood already
works a little bit with how they
organize for a project you decide where
to take the project or not the contract
is right there in the spot you get paid
a certain amount you get rated every day
or every week you get the mind delivered
and then when you're done working you
turn it off and you go to Tahiti or
wherever you want to spend the next
three months and I think the smart
people have already started figuring out
that the internet enables this and
they're starting to work more and more
remotely on their own schedule on their
own time and their own place with their
own friends in their own way and that's
actually how we are the most productive
so the information revolution by making
it easier to communicate connect and
cooperate is allowing us to go back to
working for ourselves and that is my
ultimate dream even when I run a company
and I have employees I always tell those
people hey I'm gonna help you start your
company when you're ready because I
think that's the highest calling maybe
not everybody will get there but it
would be fine if we were even working a
10 person company or 20 person company
is way better than working in a thousand
person company 10,000 person company so
this idea that we're all factory like
cogs in a machine who are specialized
and have to do things by rote
memorization or instruction is going to
go away and we're going to go back to
being small groups of creative bands of
individuals setting out to do missions
and when those missions are done we
collect our money we get rated and then
we rest and reassess until we're ready
for the next sprint has there ever been
a study done on happiness and as it
regards to the size of companies not
that I'm aware but to me it's obvious
it's just obvious this is more of the
company that happy you're gonna be the
more human your relations are the less
you have rules to operate under the more
flexible the more creative the more you
betray like a human just because you're
able to do multiple things yeah
this brings me to but is a subject that
keeps getting brought up nowadays is
universal basic income with the oncoming
yeah apocalypse of automation this is
how it's being portrayed by Andrew yang
who's running for president and I sat
down talked with him about it's very
compelling and he's a very smart guy and
he's an entrepreneur himself and when he
starts talking about automation and how
it's going to just eliminate massive
amounts of jobs and leave people
stranded what do you when I know you're
a guy who thinks about the future and
I'm gonna play popular point of view on
this I don't think it's a non solution
to a non problem mmm and I mean that in
the sense that automation has been
happening since the dawn of time man
when electricity came along that put a
lot of people out of work did it right a
lot of people carrying buckets of water
and you know lighting lamps and all
those kinds of things and this was the
concern with factories as well perhaps
everything literally every single thing
that comes even a printing press
absolutely and what it does is it frees
people up for new creative work so the
question is not is automation going to
eliminate jobs there is no finite number
of jobs
we're not like sitting around dividing
up the same jobs that were around since
the Stone Age
so obviously new jobs are being created
and they're usually better jobs more
creative jobs so the question is how
quickly is this transition going to
happen and what kinds of jobs will be
eliminated what kinds of jobs will be
created it's impossible looking forward
to predict what kinds of jobs will be
created if I told you 10 years ago that
podcaster was gonna be a job or that you
know playing video games is gonna be a
job or commentating on video games is
gonna be a job you would have laughed me
out of the room those are nonsense jobs
but yet here we are so society will
always create new jobs civilization
creates new jobs but it's impossible to
predict what those jobs are so the
question is how quickly is that
transition happening well the reality is
even though everybody keeps talking
about this automation apocalypse we're
at a record low unemployment explain
that where's the transition Donald Trump
that's hard all I'm saying is it's it's
it's I don't see it in the numbers I
don't see it actually happening the
question is how quickly can you retrain
people so it's an education problem the
problem in the ubi there's a couple of
problems at UVI one is you're creating a
straight
you creating a slippery slide transfer
straight into socialism right the moment
people can start voting themselves money
combined with the democracy well it's
just a matter of time before the bottom
fifty one votes themselves everything
the top forty line yeah and it just it
and by the slippery slope fallacy is not
a fallacy and I know people like saying
that but they haven't thought it through
but the moment you start having a direct
transfer mechanism like that in a
democracy you're basically doing it with
capitalism which is the engine of
economic growth
you're also forcing the entrepreneurs
out or telling them not to come here the
estimate I saw for 15k a year basic
income for everybody would be
three-quarters of current GDP and of
course GDP was shrinking responses all
the entrepreneurs fled so you would
essentially bankrupt the country
another issue at UVI is that people who
are down on their luck they're not
looking for handouts it's not just about
money it's also about status it's about
meaning and the moment I start giving
money to you and put you on the dole
I've lowered your status I've made you a
second-class citizen so I have to give
you meaning and meaning comes to
education and capability I have you have
to teach a man to fish not to basically
throw your rotting leftover carcasses
that have and say here eat the scraps so
it doesn't solve the meaning problem and
lastly it's nonsense to hand 15k out to
everybody you wanna means-test people
there's no reason to give it to you and
me so you end up back towards the
welfare system where you do have to
figure out who needs it and who doesn't
so I think the better route is that we
actually establish a set of basic
substance services that you have to have
and we provide those in abundance
through technology-based automation so
get basic housing get basic food get
basic transportation get high-speed
internet access get a phone in your
pocket those are the kinds of things you
want to give people and finally in terms
of the rate of automation I think we can
educate people very quickly one of the
myths that we have today is that adults
can't be re-educated we view education
as this thing where you go to school you
come out when you're out of college and
you're done no more education well
that's wrong you have all these great
online boot camps and coding schools
coming up they're ones that'll even pay
you to go there now
you can educate people and mass and you
can educate them in to create a
professions people who are talking about
AI automating programming have never
really written serious code coding is
thinking it's automatic structural
thinking an AI that can program as well
or better than humans is an AI that just
took over the world
that's endgame and that's the end of the
human species and I can give you
arguments why I don't think that's
coming either people who are thinking
and I know I take the opposite side from
some very famous people in this debate
but we're nowhere near close to
generally AI not in our lifetimes you
don't have to worry about it even in our
lifetimes really it's so overblown it's
it's another it's a combination of
Cassandra complex you know it's fun to
talk about the end of the world combined
with a god complex like people who have
lost religion so they were looking for
meaning in some kind of end of history
right the reason why I don't think AI is
coming anytime soon is because a lot of
the advances in so-called AI today or
what we call narrow AI they're really a
pattern recognition machine learning to
figure out like what is that object on
the screen or how do you find this
signal and all that noise
there is nothing approaching what we
call creative thinking to actually model
general intelligence you run into all
kinds of problems first we don't know
how the brain works at all number two
we've never even modeled a Paramecium or
an amoeba let alone a human brain number
three there's this assumption that all
of the computation is going at the
cellular level at the neuron level where
nature is very parsimonious it uses
everything else disposal there's a lot
of machinery inside the cell that is
doing calculations that is intelligent
that is an accounted for and the best
estimates are it would take 50 years of
Moore's law before we can simulate
what's going on inside a cell near
perfectly and probably a hundred years
before we can build a brain that can
simulate inside the cells so putting it
at saying that I'm just gonna model
neuron is on or off and then use that to
build a human brain is overly simplistic
furthermore I would posit there's no
such thing as general intelligence every
intelligence is contextual within the
context of the environment that it's in
so you have to evolve an environment
around it so I think a lot of people who
are peddling general AI the burden of
proof is on them I haven't seen anything
that would lead me to indicate we're
approaching general AI instead we're
solving deterministic close-set finally
problems using large amounts of data but
it's not sexy to talk about that if you
you're talking about mirroring the
actual abilities of cells or are you
talking about recreating the actual
mechanism like what what what is going
on inside cells and and biological
organisms yeah we just don't know how
intelligence works right we don't know
really no idea
so most of the AAI approaches basically
say we're gonna try and model how the
brain works but then model at the neuron
level which is saying this neurons on
that neurons off they're combining their
signal but I'm saying in the neuron is a
cell inside the cell there's all this
machinery going on that's operating the
neuron that is also part of the
intelligence apparatus you can't just
ignore that and abstract that out you
have to model it down to the inside the
cell level it's also a part of the
biological organism itself exam and it
has all these needs that you know the
biological organism has to have food and
rest and exactly the balance going on
but when you eliminate all that when
there is none of that and it's just
calculations and we get to a point where
it's just this thing that we've created
whether you call it a computer whether
it doesn't have to be a moving thing
even but a thing that you've created
that stores virtually all the
information that's available in the
world stores all the patterns of all the
thinking of all the great people that
have ever lived all the the writers all
the people that have ever published
anything all the people that have ever
spoken any words stores all of their
points all the counter points all their
contradictions applies logic and reason
and some sort of sense of the future and
starts improving upon these patterns and
then starts acting on its own based on
the information that it's been provided
with where's well first you would have
to actually simulate a structure of the
human brain that can hold all that
information you're basically talk about
tens of thousands of brains worth of
information right
we can't even build one brain in the
next decade or two or three well in
terms of an actual physical brain yes
what about something that recreates the
abilities of a brain like I said nature
is parsimonious so we've got this
three-pound wetware object that can hold
all this data Nature has been very
efficient in evolving kind of how we get
there
I just don't think computers are
anywhere close to that like that it can
hold that amount of data with that
complexity with like the holographic
structure of the brain working recall in
many many different ways and then I
don't think you can evolve a creature to
be intelligent outside of the boundaries
of feedback in a real medium like if you
evolved if you raised a human being a
concrete cell with no input from the
outside they wouldn't have any feedback
from the real world
they were evolved properly so I think
just dumping information into into a
thing isn't enough it has to have an
environment to operate in to get
feedback from it needs to have context
but isn't that biological I mean what if
you--if you have just the all the
information that people have accumulated
and the lessons that people have learned
and you program that into the computer
like if if we can take a computer that
can beat someone at chess the the real
question was well can we make some sort
of an artificial intelligent could beat
someone that go which is far more
complex of chess they figured out how to
do that too and that was a giant shock
right these are still man-made very
closed bounded games they're they're not
they're not on the road to the unbounded
game of life they are completely
artificial but this didn't go didn't
that give you a little bit of a pause a
little bit go is not go or League of
Legends a fortnight they're not
completely deterministic right but
they're still very artificial very about
ed games being good at go doesn't mean
that you can then suddenly figure out
how to write great poetry right the
creativity for sure is something that
some creativity is the last frontier so
I do believe that automation over long
enough period of time will replace every
non creative job hmm or every non
creative work but that's great news that
means that all of our basic needs are
taken care of and what remains for us is
to be creative which is really what
every human wants yeah
when what are you doing right now this
is a creative job sure that brings us
back to the
the idea of meaning and universal basic
income I think the idea of giving
someone $15,000 a year doesn't
necessarily cause whatever what everyone
would worry about is Pele being on the
dole you would have a bunch of listless
people out there with no meaning in life
but the idea is that $15,000 a year and
I'm not necessarily sure I agree with
this I'm not even endorsing this but
that $15,000 a year we just provide you
with the necessities to get by in life
it would give you food it would give you
shelter well it's not going to stop at
15 because the moment people like I mean
15 like they're people and more Bernie
Sanders would be on those 16 companies
are too big yeah that case it doesn't it
doesn't stop it just it just goes all
the way to bankruptcy the concern is to
slide to socialism it's obvious yeah I
mean heck if I was on if I was not
working and I was getting my 15 a year I
would happily vote for the guy who'd
give me 20 or 25 is this common sense
what do you say to the people that don't
believe that there is such a thing of
ethical as ethical or compassionate
capitalism there's many people today
that are espousing Marxism and they're
espousing some sort of a socialist
society where they believe that
capitalism has screwed people over and
eliminated the middle class and there
are absolutely problems with capitalism
I think monopolies are a problem I think
that crony capitalism is a problem with
the government you know kind of gets in
bed with them and sort of forces things
I think the bankers have really you know
raped society and the rest of us are
suffering literally yeah they've
essentially taking huge risks where they
privatized the gains and the socialize
the losses so when it fails they
basically get bailed out and bankrupt
everybody else so capitalism has gotten
a really bad name let's talk about his
free exchange free markets free markets
and free exchange or intrinsic to humans
from when the first person started a
fire and somebody came along with a deer
and said hey if I cook my dear and your
fire I'll share some of it with you
right so specialization of Labor we
trade that's built into the human
species basic math comes from accounting
keeping track of debts and credits and
so on we need to be able to engage in
free trade the correct criticism of
capital
is when it does not provide equal
opportunity and so we should always
strive to provide equal opportunity but
people confuse that with equal outcome
when you have equal outcome that can
only be enforced through violence
because different people free people
make different choices and when they
make different choices they have
different outcomes if you don't let them
suffer the consequences of bad choices
or reap the rewards from good choices
then you are forcibly redistributing
through violence it's interesting that
there isn't there are no socialists
working socialists examples that exist
without violence you basically need
someone to show up with a gun and say
okay you're not allowed to do that you
hand this over to that person so one of
the reasons why do this podcast is
because I believe everybody can be
wealthy everybody it's not a zero-sum
game it is a positive sum game you
create something brand new you exchange
it with me for something brand new I've
created there's higher utility for both
of us the sum of the value created is
positive it's not like status where it's
like you're higher up I'm lower down
you're president so I must be vice
president
you're a plus one I'm a minus one it has
to cancel a zero we should all be all
for playing positive some ethical games
the problem is because of these looters
who have ruined capitalism's name but
then you get socialists coming in and
saying burn the whole system down right
you burn the whole system down we end up
like Venezuela or the former Soviet
Union you know you don't want to be a
fail socialist states with emaciated
teens hunting cats in the streets to eat
right that's literally what happens in
some of these places so I think it's
very important not to destroy the engine
of progress that brought us here yeah
the idea that socialism just hasn't
worked yet that it needs to the didn't
we just need to do it right if we do it
right we can net you if you ever 100
hundred million dead and yeah yeah well
let's keep trying all over the world
yeah and in every single time it's
implemented the have you ever had a
conversation with someone who's a
socialist who many times so am I better
better friends or socialists really we
really get into it yeah and what is
there I mean does anyone have a
compelling perspective at all I I think
really socialism comes from the heart
right you all we all want to be
socialist capitalism comes from the head
because they're always cheaters in any
system yes and there's incentives and
insist
so when you're young if you're if you're
not a socialist you have no heart when
you're older if you're not a capitalist
you have no head right you haven't
thought it through so I understand where
it comes from I always like Nassim Taleb
ceramic um this where he said with my
family I am a communist with my close
friends I am a socialist you know at my
state level politics I'm a Democrat at
you know higher levels I'm a I'm a
Republican and at the federal level I'm
a libertarian right so basically the
larger the group of people you have
mashed together who have different
interests the less trust there is the
more cheating there is the better the
incentives have to be aligned the better
the system has to work the more you go
towards capitalism the smaller the group
you're in you're in a kibbutz you're in
your commie and you're in your house you
and your tribe by all means be a
socialist with my aunts with my brother
with my cousins and my uncle's with my
mom but yeah family I'm a socialist
that's the right way to live a loving
happy integrated life yes but when
you're dealing with strangers I mean you
want to be a real socialist great open
all your doors and windows tomorrow
please everybody come take what you want
see how that works out yeah
this idea of income inequality that
always strikes me as a very it's a
deceptive term income inequality well
let's flip it around
it comes from outcome inequality yeah
and the outcome inequality is there
because you made different choices now
again going back if it was because you
don't have the same opportunities that's
a problem yes so society should always
try to give people equal opportunities
so for example instead of basic income
what if we had a retraining program
built into our basic social fabric which
said that every four years or every six
years or whatever it is maybe it's every
ten you can take one year out and we'll
pay for you to go retrain completely and
you can go into any profession you like
that has some earning power and output
hopefully a creative long term
profession and you can re-educate
yourself that would be much better for
society on all levels than basically
just saying now you're gonna be the dole
for the rest of your life mmm
yeah just you'd have to lead that horse
to water and then make him drink it
requires people to put in some effort
yes you know we can't all just sit
around it's just not well that's my
perspective
income inequality there's always effort
in equality and and thought any quality
there's just some people that are
obsessed and if those people become
successful it doesn't mean they stole
from you it just means that they put in
the amount of energy and effort that was
required to reach where they're at and
there's a lot of riches signaling that
goes on now people say well it's because
you're privileged the greatest
privileges you're alive from eighty five
percent of humanity is dead yeah so how
privileged are you then you're living in
the first world and you're you know you
have four limbs etc so you can take that
argument all the way it's kind of a
nonsense discussion what's a very weird
progressive argument and in it as it
pertains to race is always a weird one
right because white privilege to me
although it you could look at what
they're saying on paper like yes yeah
I'm sure there's more black people that
are harassed by the police I'm sure
there is more black people who are
treated suspiciously by shop owners and
the like but the problem isn't the
people who aren't treated poorly the
problem is the people who treat the
people poorly the problem is racism the
problem is not people that didn't ask to
be born white or whatever they are and
they don't get harassed that so this
idea of white privilege or male
privilege or whatever it is that's not
the problem
you'reyou're just looking at someone
who's not a victim of this particular
problem that you're highlighting but
you're not looking at the perpetrators
of the problem you're making people
perpetrators by simply existing and
having less melanin in their skin or
having their ancestors conscious racism
by another it's a sneaky way racist yeah
and then they say you can't be racist
you it's not racist because you're white
that is hilarious if you can't be racist
against white people that one I thought
is a variation of the whole still while
I hit you argument you know it's not
struggling while I'm hitting you but
it's just so silly you've just
completely changed what racism means but
what's hilarious is it mostly the people
who are yelling racist or not the
minorities when I look on my Twitter or
my social media or on my news it's white
on white violent virtue signal yeah it's
white on white violence yeah mostly
going on is it's elitist White's blue
state whites college-educated whites
beating up on high school-educated why
it's blue collar
it's a white collar versus blue collar
war that's going on and the rest of us
are just kind of watching like oh that's
kind of interesting well it's also a
side effect of the ability to broadcast
right like everyone with a Twitter
handle has the ability to broadcast
everyone with a Facebook page has the
ability to pontificate and have these
long rambling these huge statements that
people put out when you read them it's
like how much time did you put in this
and what the [ __ ] do you put that much
time of your kids oh yeah okay job with
your life or your future or planning for
you you know what how much do you work
out a day I mean you just these some
I've read some people's Facebook posts
I'm like this is a preposterous amount
of effort that you put into saying
virtually nothing
let's see humans are being creative yeah
it's an AI do that well that's true it
is creative it's it's creative in a very
odd way right because it's creative and
that they're trying to elicit a response
from people and they're trying to raise
their there's social value or raise
their position the social totem pole
it's signaling and it's easy signaling
because the kind of thing that everybody
has to agree with you on because nobody
wants to be seen as a horrible person
yeah and it's very hard to make the
nuanced arguments against then this is
just kind of go along right well it's
also it's some of it is so cliche that
it seems like I I know one guy who poses
as a woman on Twitter but he does it
just well obviously yeah what is this
the name Tatiana
McGrath yeah yeah you got real wick yeah
oh is that the same guy I think so yeah
that's hilarious I did not they killed
his account they confirm that hundred
percent sure we're pretending to be
transracial that's right they didn't let
ya he basically says all the crazy stuff
yes people on the left say but he says
the craziest version yes and kind of
just shows how it's okay like I think I
saw a tweet when recently just said or
her that it's not okay to be white and
some people agree it's it's so close to
what they say it's so close that it's
like the most artful form of subtle
parody because if you if you replace in
half of these things if you replace the
word white with black or Asian
what's the lynch mob dissent yeah yeah
it's it's a strange time in that respect
that favor something better if you want
to see who rules over you see who you're
not allowed to criticize mmm excellent
yeah
that is a that's so true right yeah
that's so true
I wonder where this is going I really do
I wonder because this is it seems like
this newfound ability to broadcast that
we have with whether you have a YouTube
page or the other Twitter or whatever
you're doing this newfound ability to
spread whatever you're trying to say to
so many people with very little
understanding on the most part from what
I think it's actually a great thing
overall yeah means that any human can
broadcast to any other human on the
planet at anytime so for example if you
know a totalitarian dictator were to
come to power and someone was beating up
you know had fascists beating up on old
women like that would get broadcast out
instantly there would be an instant
outrage hue and cry rallying so in that
sense it helps bring attention to the
plight of anybody but right now we're
going through the phase where we have
this newfound power to assemble mobs and
people don't know how to deal with that
so it becomes very easy to set up a mob
and have it attack somebody take all the
context out like even this conversation
I'm sure people will take out snippets
to put them on social media and try and
get somebody outraged of course and so
you have to learn how first of all
society just has to get over this idea
of outrage like to me like out rich
people just people get easily outraged
of the stupidest people on social media
those are the people I block instantly
it's just kind of very low-level
thinking right these are the foots of
that these are the foot soldiers in a
mob eventually society just has to get
over it they have to understand that
these are all snippets being taken out
of context these are doctored video
clips these are just someone who's
trying to get outraged or something
eventually they'll also be anti mob
tactics like for example if I go to
someone's Twitter feed and all it is is
full of political ranting raving
conspiracy theories do I want to work
with this person
do I want to sociate with this person
doing any friends with this person their
mind is just cluttered with junk now I
don't necessarily blame
I think that the human brain is not
designed to absorb all the world's
breaking news 24/7 emergencies injected
straight into your skull with clickbait
headline news if you pay attention to
that stuff even if you're well-meaning
even if you're sound of mind and body it
will eventually drive you insane
this is goes back to Clockwork Orange
where he's you know has his eyes open
forced to watch the news but I think
that's what's happening right now
because these are addictive right a
twitter facebook Instagram these are
weaponized you have social statisticians
and scientists and researchers on people
in lab coats literally best minds of our
generation is figuring out how to
addicted to the news yes and if you fall
for it if you get addicted your brain
will get destroyed and I think this is
the modern struggle like the modern
struggle so the ancient struggle used to
be the tribal struggle you had your
tribe of friends and family you had your
religion you had your country you had
your loyalty your internationality at
least you had meaning and support but
now you would struggle against other
tribes modern life were so free
everything's become atomized we stand
alone you live in your apartment alone
and you live in your house alone and
your parents don't live nearby your
friends don't live nearby you don't have
any tribal meaning you don't believe in
religion anymore you don't believe in
country anymore it's fine you got a lot
of freedoms fantastic but now when they
come to attack you you're alone and you
can resist so how do they attack you
it's all well-meaning I don't fault
capitalism I love capitalism but look at
how it happens social media
they've massaged all the mechanisms too
addictive like a Skinner pigeon or a rat
who's just gonna click click click click
click can't put the phone down the food
they've taken sugar and they've
weaponized it they've put it into all
these different forms and varieties that
you can't resist eating drugs right
they've taken pharmaceuticals and plants
and they've synthesized them they've
grown them in such a way that you can't
you get addicted you can't put them down
porn right if you're a young male you
wander around the internet it'll like
zap away your libido and you're not
going out in real life society anymore
because you've got this incredibly
stimulating stuff coming at you video
games another way to dig people so you
have this you have entire large
factories of people that are
working to addicted to these things and
you stand alone so the modern struggle
as an individual is learning how to
resist these things in the first place
drawing your own boundaries and there's
no one there to help you move that's
terrifying it is a new road that needs
to be navigated by young people that are
there's no map
there's no guidebook on how to handle
this our generation is the transition
generation I think kids will know how to
handle it better because they'll grow up
it I hope I hope I hope to because
you're seeing some ridiculous behavior
from people today that's so common I
mean I don't know if you've been paying
attention to this but there was a guy
who he made a video of turns out it
wasn't even him that made the video at
least that's not what he said but it was
a video where he sort of doctored Nancy
Pelosi talking and made it look like she
was drunk and then a bunch of people
retweeted it like oh my god look she's
drunken and so one of the online
publications some website tracked him
down and doxxed him and turned out he's
just a day laborer who is an African
American Trump fan and thought it would
be funny to do that and it turns out
that he didn't even at least according
him he actually just put it up on his
Facebook page what's even more
disturbing is Facebook gave up his
information to this website right for
what cuz he made something funny that
made people seem drunk there's a million
of those about me I mean you could find
them I mean I think Facebook and Twitter
and a bunch of these other social media
platforms are committing a slow-motion
suicide through these kinds of
activities that was a stunning one
though that they would give up this guy
who's a laborer because he made a parody
video or he made someone look foolish
with editing well you now have basically
the media you views it as their job to
go after individuals they don't like I
used media with air quotes in that
regard I don't think this is something
that the New York Times and any sponsor
Mopa but the media is getting more and
more desperate right because what
happened was before the internet you
could have two local newspapers in every
town and you could have two local news
stations TV stations in every town and
then CNN came along and started
commoditizing than you
24/7 broadcasts and then the internet
came along that was the final nail on a
coffin because what the internet did was
it said actually if there's a fact
that's news you can distribute that
immediately they can go on Twitter it
can go on Facebook it gets reprinted in
Google News a thousand times you know
you go on Google News you're like okay
what's the piece of news which source
and three thousand other articles too
many right yeah so News has become
commoditized so the entire news media
has shifted into peddling opinions and
entertainment yes and so now they've
become a variation between like
cheerleaders shock troops enforcers you
know Talking Heads so these are now
tribal but these are not propaganda
machines signaling for their tribes it's
a right-wing one this left-wing one
right there's the alt right there's a
control left and the two of them were
just fighting it out using their various
media organs and memes so basically when
you see one of these news organizations
daxing an individual that's like a tank
running over a soldier I mean that's
what's going on it's just war and so
there's no there's no such thing anymore
as a neutral media commentator the the
illusion of objectivity that journalism
had is lost
there's no longer one guy like a Walter
Cronkite that everyone's gonna listen to
it's now all just shock troops fighting
wars with each other how does this play
out have you thought about it yeah a
little bit so what the Internet does a
lot of this is internet driven what the
internet does is the internet creates
one giant aggregator or two for
everything one taxi dispatcher one
ecommerce store one search engine one
you know one social media site for
friends and family one for business etc
so the Internet is this giant aggregator
where it creates one big hegemon for
everything and it creates an atomized
long tail of millions and millions of
individuals what it gets rid of is the
medium medium sized ones in the middle
so for example you might have had like
seven Hollywood studios what's all gonna
be Netflix you had you know like ten
large e-commerce players at commerce
players from Walmart Costco to you know
Kmart and whatever not just gonna be
Amazon and a ton of small individual
brands so that's the world that we're
headed towards one hegemon and millions
of individuals so where it ends up
long-term is media will be a few
gigantic outlets you know it could be
the New York Times it could be Facebook
a few like that and there's gonna be
just a really long tail of millions of
independent people so this idea of who's
a journalist and who's not you know it's
Assange a journalist or not everyone's a
journalist that's the world that we're
headed towards I do think that extreme
power the most powerful people in the
world today and this is not well known
but the most powerful people in the
world today or the people who are
writing the algorithms for Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram because they're
controlling the spread of information
they're literally rewriting people's
brains their programming the culture and
they're doing it very subtly like Google
I believe that you know one of their
execs got up in front of Congress and
the congressman asked him you know do
you manipulate search results and he
said no we do not manipulate search
results really that's your job that is
literally all Google does Google has one
job which is to manipulate search
results to pull him out of the noise and
rank them properly and the at the
precise algorithms of how they do that
is very hidden very complex but
influences the hearts and minds of
everybody including all the voters now
if Google Facebook and Twitter had been
smart about this they would not have
picked sides they would have said we're
publishers whatever goes through our
pipes goes through our pipes if it's
illegal we'll take it down
give us a court order otherwise we don't
touch it it's like the phone company if
I call you up and I say something
horrible to you on the phone the phone
company doesn't get in trouble but the
moment they started taking stuff down
that wasn't illegal because somebody
screamed they basically lost a right to
be viewed as a carrier and now all of a
sudden they've taken on liability so
they're sliding down the slippery slope
into ruin slope into ruin where the left
wants him to take down the right the
right wants gonna take down the left and
now they have no more friends they have
no allies traditionally the libertarian
leaning Republicans and Democrats would
have stood up in principle for the
common carriers but now they won't so my
guess is as soon as Congress and this is
this day is coming if not already here
it might even been here today actually
because they saw something related in
the news the day is coming when the
politicians realize
that these social media platforms are
picking the next president the next
congressman they're literally picking
and they have the power to pick so they
will be controlled by the government in
what way how do you think they're gonna
be controlled well you think they're
gonna have to adhere to strict
principles of freedom of speech no no
unfortunately as head of the opposite
direction yeah I wish it was freedom of
speech much more likely they're gonna be
in the short to medium term they're
gonna be hauled in for hearings they're
gonna be pressured massively do this
don't do that my concern about that is
the the hearings that I saw with
Zuckerberg those people were completely
incompetent they don't seem to
understand you know they don't but
they're just applying pressure they're
just trying to scare him so he'll do
what they want and what do they want him
to do they want him to basically
suppress the other side so if you're
right-wing you want to suppress the
left-wing if you're left doing you want
to suppress the right-wing and if you
just see where these companies are
headquartered in Silicon Valley all the
sensors and that's really what they are
there are sensors working inside these
companies they're just called they call
by different names obviously rights
doublespeak he called the department
defense when it's a department of war so
in this case the Department of Safety
and Trust but really it's a department
of censorship the censors are inside
Silicon Valley so it's going to reflect
Silicon Valley's politics which is
extremely progressive left-wing yeah and
if you're not that you really have no
place there's right try being a
conservative an open conservative at
Google good luck now you get lynched yes
it's crazy I mean I don't think that
there was ever a thing like that
that was so influential and so
politically ideologically one-sided yeah
there's a there's a little thing on the
internet think it's called conquest law
that any organization that's not
explicitly left the right wing
eventually becomes left wing and I don't
know why that's true but it does seem to
me to be true let's say it's a
fascinating battle that's going on right
now I mean it really is and
conservatives in as far as social media
is concerned they're just getting
chopped off at the hams left and right
yeah what'll eventually happen is that
whatever you suppress speech the
organism metastasizes then it has to
start turning towards other means if
you're unlucky it goes towards violence
if you're lucky they find other outlets
I think what will happen is we will
start creating decentralized media
that's not owned by any single entity
that can't be suppressed or shut down
that will then start spreading these
various things and that will take the
place of Twitter or Facebook or travel
but it's gonna take 10 years 20 years
it's not overnight well you know Twitter
took 10 years to get to the point where
it's at this mess right now but it was
so interesting to to have Jack Dorsey
and to talk to him about where it's
going where he thinks it's going in his
own principles which he believes that
it's a fundamental right and he believes
that freedom of speech is something that
we all should have and that these
platforms should essentially be like
like utilities like The Electric Company
Jack is correct and he has the right
vision it's just he's in an organization
where the other individuals in the
organization feel differently very
differently so the organization itself
can get hijacked and his timeline for
changing things it's like it's decades
yeah I know I shouldn't say decades but
I mean I was like when do you think that
something but there's a part of it was
one idea of having an uncensored Twitter
like one Twitter that's the Wild West
like you can have regular Twitter or you
could try Wild West Twitter like well
that already exists is a network called
gab yeah app isn't even Wild West
Twitter they when when people Docs
people they remove things like that yeah
I mean I think there's certainly lines
around violence and illegality that you
don't want to cross but yes gap is
closer to free speech platform but it's
still not decentralized it can still get
shut down it gets taken out it's also
suppressed heavily yes so that so there
and the people on there right now are
extremely right-wing so it's not a
pleasant place for someone like me to
hang out what's all that
people that have been kicked off of
something else so that's right try going
over there and being moderate try going
over there there's no room for you yeah
unfortunately because I don't identify
as any party or anything Creed you know
it doesn't work for me
is that a problem in Silicon Valley when
you don't identify as anything did you
get pressure totally it used to be okay
it's not okay anymore
when was it okay like ten years ago I
would say it was okay and then he
started seeing a shift yeah and now you
have two picks
otherwise you automatically the enemy
real ya struggle sessions and all that
struggle sessions I'm exaggerating for
but it definitely has that oppressive
feeling to it right and you also have to
be politically outspoken yeah it can't
be something that you just stay neutral
about right it's like when Tim Ferriss I
think at some point put out a tweet
about how you can't just say anything
anymore and you know people are being
suppressed and a whole bunch of people
who loved them from Silicon Valley piled
and said what is it that you can't say
what are you afraid to say you can say
whatever you want him go ahead what are
you afraid of what was he trying to say
well we have to put him in that box what
is someone who's thinking about saying
something he shouldn't have said exactly
how we know one great tweet I saw was
you know the left one the culture wars
now they're just driving around shooting
the survivors Wow
that's hilarious yeah I wonder I wonder
who as has won the culture war there's
certainly a battle that's been won in
terms of like control of social media
control of social media is absolutely
laughable this is unfortunate for
conservatives but technology is a force
that also pushes left so if you look all
throughout human history like the left
essentially grows and grows and grows
right why is that why is it inexorably
that as some commentators have said
Leviathan slouches left right from the
Maya --then is the government why does
this slush left and I think a lot of
that has been because of technology
technology has made it so that it makes
more like Industrial Revolution
technology we all band together we're
Ward's of the state
right contraception is a technology that
it kind of helps lean leftward it takes
away from the family unit abortion is a
technology right it was impossible
thousands of years ago so technology
actually empowers the individual the
individual means that you have the
breakdown of family structure and
religion and all that and I'm not asleep
post at that but it does mean that
there's a leftward shift to it now we
are getting a small set of technologies
that actually can take you more
rightward encryption as an example
because encryption makes it easier to
have privacy it makes it easier to have
money that is outside of the state
guns 3d printing of guns is an example
of a technology that is more of a
rightward shift but generally technology
leads the world left
yeah it's it's also usually highly
educated people that are involved in
technology in the first place and I
think when you look at universities in
particular they tend to lean left in
this country as well
well universities what happened to the
university is very interesting
universities first when you know became
the arbiters of data and intellectualism
and what's right and wrong so the time
period when it was like should we be
doing that or not well let's look at the
university what do they have to say what
are the smartest people the professors
that think tanks have to say and the
universities got this credibility from
the hard sciences so they got this from
you know physics and math and computer
science and chemistry because these
deliver real things the Manhattan
Project the microprocessor the space
vehicles and so on the electric car so
they gained this mantle of authority and
legitimacy from the hard sciences so
then come the social sciences kind of
sneaked in then you get economy
economics and microeconomics is a real
discipline real science real math behind
it logic reason and then you get
macroeconomics which can be politicized
a little bit more voodoo and then you
get social studies and then you get
Gender Studies and then you get blah
blah blah blah blah blah
and so what happened is that because we
took scientists to be the high priests
of our new world science itself has
gotten corrupted and the social sciences
and you can tell they're fake sciences
because they're the word science tacked
on at the end have come in and hijacked
the universities and become the new
think tanks and so essentially what you
see going on today in the universities
is a war between the social sciences and
the physical sciences and the crossover
point is biology right where you can see
like the whole gender is a social
construct movement is attacking biology
and evolutionary biology just like in
the social sphere they're coming after
the comedians right but you can see the
struggle going on the universities and I
would say the physical sciences are
essentially losing that war what can be
done or is it just something that has to
play out is it do we have to realize the
consequences of the foolishness well the
good news is the physical sciences have
a reality on their side
yeah but it's not even I mean in many
ways it's not respected yeah but you at
the end of the day your your aircraft
still has to fly you know your
microprocessor still has to compute and
so there's only so far they can they can
take it but I do see for example in
biology a lot of biologists are facing
this difficult thing where they have to
save things that they know are not true
to keep their job like what oh you had
Brett Weinstein on here mm-hmm right so
that's that's a clear example so there's
just the crossover line of what is
acceptable what's not is entering into a
biology and biology will probably suffer
the most synthetic biology for example
will you know a lot of this will end up
in China because it won't be you you
won't be able to map facts and reality
and actions together you won't be able
to get grants you won't be able to get
the adulation of your peers I don't I
don't know enough here so now I'm in
shakey territory but it's just my sense
that that crossover battleground right
now is in evolutionary biology economics
lost
well it's certainly in terms of gender
and that that sort of that seems to be
one of the major battlegrounds yeah it's
also gonna happen we have a blank slate
theory you know are we nature or we
nurture it's kind of socially
unacceptable to say that you know a lot
of it is nature and not nurture or vice
versa depending on which side you're on
right those kinds of discussions get
corrupted they do get corrupted and it's
really unfortunate because that's an
unbelievably important thing to
understand like what makes a person a
sociopath what makes a person a super
successful person a winner
what makes a person a drug addict what
would are what are these factors you
can't have a reasonable conversation
about climate science anymore it's not a
science Ultima sized you can't even
bring it up everyone's got their minds
made up already well it's what's
uncomfortable to me is people have their
minds made up and they don't even have
the data on most of these topics people
are talking past each other anyway talk
about different things like when you get
into you know when you when you get into
gun control for example right one side
is talking about the right to bear arms
in case a tyrannical ruler or King tries
to take over the country the other time
the other
it's talking about school shootings and
you know protecting people in their
homes right from crime so they're just
talking about two different things right
and it's just not politically acceptable
to even talk about the same thing or
when you gets to immigration the right
is talking about you know the other left
is like bundling together illegal
immigration and legal immigration into
one thing yes right we're in the on the
right sometimes you got racist hiding in
there so it doesn't help their cause
I've been talking about two different
things
yeah if they were talking about the same
thing which is how many immigrants
should we let into the country and you
know what are the criteria for that that
would be a very different conversation
than no immigrants or everybody comes in
and then also on the left you know you
have this benefit that everybody who's
currently coming in illegally is gonna
vote for the left because of where
they're coming from and their
socio-economic circumstances hmm to me
the test of any good system is you build
a system hand it over to your enemies to
run for the next decade so for example
if you want a censorship on Twitter or
Facebook you should build that system
and then hand it over to the other side
to run so if you're a left winger who's
promoting censorship that's somebody
else running same with immigration if
you want immigration system build the
system then hand it over to the other
side to running there's how you know
it's a good system there's no room for
nuance when you're dealing with these
political battlegrounds when when you're
dealing with right versus left and one
side has a clearly established stance
that you're supposed to take
particularly gun controls great example
of that right there's no room for what
about mental health what about the fact
that so many of these people are on
psych medication right what why is that
not being asked we're running one of the
greatest mental health experiments in
history when we're doping everybody up
and SSRIs yeah and you know maybe if you
give thirty million people
SSRIs maybe like twenty nine point nine
million or a lot happier and then you
have a fraction that commits suicide or
detonate yeah you're basically trading
the mean for the variance right
you have blow up risk yeah there's no
room for nuance which is why I stay out
of politics largely do they drag you in
though sometimes I always try and he's
conversation is conversation you get to
get dragged in sure but I'm sure there's
gonna be some people here's the thing
about politics because there
we have a first-past-the-post system
what that means is that whoever wins 51%
of the vote in this country gets a lot
of the power right it's not like
proportional representation where the
Greens have 10% and you know the
libertarians or 3% or whatever it's just
like you're all Democrat and power now
all Republican because of that to win
you have to pick one of these two sides
right you have you have to choose you
can't just you can't just make it you
can't just basically say I'm gonna be
you know nuanced about it
you can't vote for a third party that's
throwing every vote right I have a
friend who's trying to fix that he's
starting this thing called a good party
where like you kick start your vote so
you combine all your votes you hold them
in reserve and then when you have enough
to win then you vote that person in
power right you know you don't throw
away your vote but outside of those
hacks we're never gonna get a third
party elected so because of that all of
your beliefs have to neatly fit into the
Democrat bundle or the Republican bundle
and so when you get into that tribe if
you signal outside of that try out out
of that bundle you get attacked yeah so
it's literally it's making you into an
unclear thinker it's making you into a
muddled thinker if all of your beliefs
line up into one political party you're
not a clear thinker if all your beliefs
are the same as your neighbors and your
friends you're not a clear thinker
you're literally just your beliefs are
socialized they're taken from other
people so if you want to be a clear
thinker you cannot pay attention to
politics it will destroy your ability to
think
oh but what dread most of modern life
all our diseases are diseases of
abundance not diseases of scarcity right
old times I may have starved I you know
old times if I got sugar that was a
wonderful thing I should have eaten all
the sugar to get my hands on if I got in
a piece of news or gossip that was
interesting data that would have helped
my life and move me forward if I'd
gotten some brief amount of
entertainment whether through video
games or magazines or whatever that
would have been good now it's all
diseases of abundance
we are overexposed to everything so the
way to survive in modern society is to
be an ascetic it is to retreat from
society there's too much society
everywhere you go Society in your phone
Society in your pocket Society in your
ears
you're being socialized right now by
listening to this podcast we're
socializing you we're programming you
everyone's trying to program every
the only solution is turn it off the
only solution is to turn it off and
concentrate on your breathing meditation
yeah yes it works it's it's been a
lifesaver for me oh I do it and I I do
it whenever I get like spare time I was
at the doctor's office this morning and
I knew it was gonna be twenty minutes so
I just sat there with my eyes closed for
twenty minutes and I melted you know
when I was growing up there was this
statement I think it was Pascal he said
you know all of man's problems arise
because he cannot sit by himself in a
room for thirty minutes alone mm-hmm and
it's very true I always needed to be
stimulated and when the iPhone came
along boredom was dead I would never be
bored again even if I'm standing in line
I'm on my iPhone and I thought it was
great and when I was a kid I used to try
and overclock my brain be like how many
thoughts gonna think at once the answer
is only one but I would try to think
multiple thoughts at once and I was
proud of that I was proud that my brain
was always running this engine was
always moving and it's a disease it's
actually the road to misery and now that
I'm older I realize like you actually
want to again rest your mind you want to
learn how to settle into your mind now I
look forward to solitary confinement you
leave me alone for a day it'll be like
the happiest day I've had in a while hmm
and and that is a superpower that I
think everybody can attain the
superpower of learning to be alone and
enjoying it yeah yeah well I think it's
critical and I and I do think that this
is these times where you just think
about things just be alone and think
about things are so rare these days and
I think during those rare times is when
you really get to understand what you
actually believe or don't believe yeah
it's it's funny when I first started
meditating it was really hard right
because everybody I think a lot of
people who were listeners broadcast have
heard of meditation that has a good rep
so everybody tries it this struggle they
kind of give it up it's one of those
things that everybody says they do but
nobody actually does right it's like not
eating sugar right everyone talks about
how yeah I don't eat sugar but like yeah
then right then the dessert trader rolls
around and everyone's going for the
cookies yeah right yeah so it's become
one of those things and in fact it's now
even become a signaling thing where it's
like oh how much did you meditate
this much or you know there are people
now wearing headband saying with tweed
birds are chirpin and when they're in
deep meditation I don't know I don't
know how they make it work but they'll
be like I got a lot of trips today how
many trips did you get oh my god oh your
meditation technique is wrong mine is
right
but really all it is is the art of doing
nothing okay and it's important because
I think when we when we grow up right
it's all this stuff happening to you in
your life and some of it you're
processing some of it you're absorbing
and some of it you should probably think
a little bit more about and work through
but you don't you don't have time so it
gets buried in you and it's all these
preferences and judgements and
unresolved situations and issues and
it's like your email inbox it's just
piling up email after email after email
that's not answered going back 10 20 30
40 years and then when you sit down to
meditate those emails start coming back
at you hey what about this issue what
about that issue have you solved this do
you think about that your regrets there
you have issues there and that gets
scary people don't want to do that it's
like it's not working I can't clear my
mind
I better get up and not do this but
really what's happening is this it's
it's self therapy it's just that instead
of paying a therapist to sit there and
listen to you listening to yourself and
you just have to sit there as those
emails go through one by one you work
through each of them until you get to
the magical inbox zero and there comes a
day when you sit down you realize the
only things you're thinking about are
the things that happen yesterday because
you've processed everything else not
necessary even resolved it but at least
listen to yourself and that's when
meditation starts and I think it's a
it's a very powerful thing that
everybody should experience and that's
when you arrive upon the art of doing
nothing well I think it's even a problem
that most people are getting their
meditation from an app I will not use an
app it's sneaky I mean Sam Harris is a
very good meditation now I should say
that but you should be able to just do
it and many people can it is literally
the art of doing nothing yeah all you
need to do for meditation is to sit down
close your eyes comfortable position
whatever happens happens if you think
you think if you don't think you don't
think don't put it effort into it don't
put effort against it all you need do
you concentrate on your breath or do you
have a specific technique nothing no no
you sit you just sit I think about my
breath that's all I do I just need to
try to only concentrate on breathing I
used to do that but it's some level all
concentration that every meditation
technique is leading you to the same
thing which is just witnessing yeah and
concentration is a technique to steal
your mind enough that you can then drop
the object of concentration so you could
also just try going straight to the
endgame the problem with what I'm
talking about which is not focusing on
your breath is you will have to listen
to your mind for a long time it's not
gonna work unless you do at least an
hour a day and preferably at least 60
days before you kind of work through a
lot of issues so it'll be held for a
while but when you come out the other
side it's great you get rid of the
chatter or when the chatter comes it's
in the background
it's dimmer it's smaller you've heard it
before you see the patterns it's more
recent it's something you need to
resolve anyway and you will get moments
of actual silence what is your what's
your ultimate state when you meditate
like is there a state where you've
achieved rarely if ever where you just
you you you're in bliss or you're in
harmony or you're in enlightenment like
whether it's time it's kind of
indescribable because when you're really
meditating you're not there when there's
no thoughts there's no experience or
there's nothing there's just nothing so
it's it's hard to describe but I would
say that it's like a you could
definitely into every psychedelic state
that people encounter using so-called
plant medicines can be arrived at just
through pure meditation and I've
definitely hit some of those states
you've hit some transcendent psychedelic
states where you're eating the whole
deal had trippy visuals I've had the
kind of delights in color the so-called
downloads I've had the realizations I've
had the bliss I've had the light the
colors but not every time no it's really
and in fact I would say that that's a
that's also like an experience that you
can start craving which will then
actually take you out of meditation
mm-hmm
were you really and I'm not enlightened
or anything close to it so not even the
ballpark but my own experience and this
is this personal experience is the place
where I end up the most that is really
the one that I I want to be at is peace
mmm it's just peace peace happy yeah
peace to me peace is happiness
rest and happiness is kind of peace in
motion you can convert peace to
happiness anytime you want but peace is
what you want most of the time that's
interesting you can convert peace
to happiness anytime you want yeah if
you're a peaceful person anything you do
will be a happy activity mmm and by the
way being on social media and engaged in
politics will not bring you peace there
is nothing less peaceful right and then
today's day and age the way we think you
get peace is by resolving all your
external problems but there's unlimited
external problems so the only way to
actually get pieces on the inside by
giving up this idea of problems who
thinks you can get peace by resolving
external problems other than politicians
everybody that's what everybody's
struggling to do right why are you
trying to make money to solve all your
money problems mm why are you trying to
win up politics because then you'll be
at peace because your people will have
won well it's a daunting task to get
your [ __ ] together it's easier to change
yourself than to change the world that's
true
and the best way to change the world is
to change yourself exactly it's all yeah
it's all these people who are shouting
on social media the best way is just to
actually live the life that you want
other people to live like I went out in
New Zealand and there's this guy that I
met with and you know everyone's on
social media shouting about
environmentalism and conserve and
sustain and I go to this guy's house and
he was doing a very quietly very gently
he was doing a two-week long zero waste
experiment where he was throwing out
nothing so every package that he opened
he would keep and he would like clean it
up so he would keep his Amazon boxes it
keeps a little container even a tea bag
if he opened the tea bag he has to
figure out how to compost the tea inside
how to make the tea itself useful how to
make the tea bag like a little storage
item so there was no trash he was
literally living with zero trash waste
and he was doing it and it was really
inspirational meeting people like him
made me far more environmentally
conscious than you know any amount of
people yelling at me on social media
ever will
how long did he do that for I think it
was two weeks it was hard what the [ __ ]
you gonna do with tea bags he had quite
the collection he was filling them with
little things he sounds like a crazy
hoarder like a hoarder person was I acts
of tea bags in his house a very
impressive guy
yeah that's a strange way to go about
things I appreciate it I mean look it is
entirely possible to somehow or another
engineer all of our cups and all of our
things and all are about to be
biodegradable you know the struggle with
a modern environmental movement is that
they identify the correct problem which
is finite earth
spaceship or the soul and God don't ruin
it but they don't have the solution so
what they say is no growth no growth no
growth well the problem is you got three
billion Indian and Chinese who aren't
gonna stay in poverty they're gonna grow
whether you like it or not so you can
yell at them you can scream at them you
can yell at us and scream at us but
that's not gonna happen so the only way
out unfortunately is again through
technology which is you have to build
green technology and I give musk a lot
of credit you know for being one of the
few people who's out there trying to do
that so you build things that are
biodegradable and good for you and
healthier and everybody wants to be
healthier Chinese want to be healthier
Indians want to be healthy or they want
to be cleaner if you say I can clean up
your rivers I can clean up your forests
I can have your children not get sick
with cholera and diphtheria and typhoid
I can cure your diseases that can help
make your immune system stronger I can
give you clean drinking water like that
is what causes people to become
environmentalist not shouting and
screaming it then that they shouldn't
grow and they should stop pumping things
into the sky and you know they have no
concept of that they're just gonna get
out of poverty so I think the modern
environmental movement identifies the
correct problem but then doesn't come up
with the right set of solutions that are
appealing to people people are not going
to give up economic growth they're gonna
have to get rich first mmm yeah that's a
very good point
but how do you do how do you do both you
lower the price of clean technologies
massively so you basically make clean
technologies cost competitive innovation
ideally you can subsidize in the short
term medium term until the innovation
curve is is crossed I mean like Tesla
doesn't have any patents right well or
they freely give away their patents
that's an example of how you can do it
so you know someone if you want to get
rid of plastic straws yeah you can do it
here and there you can get sent
go to ban plastic straws but China is
not gonna blend banned plastic straws
not until you build a paper straw that
is you know same cost good durability
and then you in then you educate Chinese
like hey this is petroleum you know this
plastic that you're doing is petroleum
is bad for you here's the chemical
composition here's the things that are
going in your bloodstream and they want
healthy happy kids also so they're gonna
have their kids use paper straws
maybe straws aren't the best example but
you can you know this is true with
fossil fuels for example that's that's
probably the best one or replacing a lot
of plastics with glass and paper and so
on yeah there's a new technology that
was just rhonda patrick editor twitter
today about they're able to convert
plastic waste into fuel and that there's
companies that are actively trying to do
that now so then in that way plastic
waste will become valuable right it'll
become a commodity it'll become
something that people are resource now
there's certain problems this doesn't
solve this doesn't solve carbon this
doesn't solve deforestation you know so
they're you kind of have to step in with
other means so for example look at the
amazon right everyone's complaining
about the amazon being deforested well
you're not the poor brazilian farmer so
you're sitting here and you're
comfortable chair like social media
hammering away at you know the evil
Brazilians were DeForest in the Amazon
but the Amazon has incredible resources
if we really care about it we should
turn it into an incredible tourist park
and put your money where your mouth is
start doing ecotourism in the Amazon
start paying for it and then maybe take
the future rights for all the
pharmaceuticals that are going to come
out of all the incredible plants there
and start selling those off so that
people so that maybe give the
pharmaceutical companies an incentive to
preserve the biodiversity the amazon say
hey if you buy this patch of the amazon
you conservative and you can serve it
whatever plant medicines that come out
of there that you can then license you
get the patent for 20 years or 30 years
or whatever so i think there are
solutions where we as the first world
leaders who have money can put our money
where where our mouth is and go and
rescue these kinds of properties that's
a very interesting solution but I could
see immediate pushback from people that
don't think the pharmaceutical company
should have the rights to this natural
plant or is or that or the government
does it and then the government gets the
patents
and the government will auction off the
patents later or they'll worse or
they'll license in or whatever it is
right well I thought in like just this
often the problem is there is no really
good solution there's a bunch of
solutions that also have drawbacks
that's life yeah that's the trade-off so
it's being human yeah very messy yeah
it's a constrained environment obviously
I skew more towards a private property
capitalist type solutions because even
though they're not perfect they have
been proven to actually work right once
something is your property you take care
of it yeah you're not gonna you're not
gonna crap all over your own house but
it should probably be temporary property
not permanent property you see a lot of
countries around the world not doing
this no foreign ownership of land thing
for example or Mexico has no private
ownership of beaches right so you can
draw the line at certain points mm-hmm
yeah do you enjoy doing this kind of
thing we break things down and give your
perspective on things and try to
illuminate certain complex subjects I'm
not I'm not trying to illuminate so much
as you know talking to you I learn as
much as I say and I learn it for myself
because I'm being forced to articulate
it I can sit around and think my
thoughts all day long but it's a lot of
its gonna be nonsense it's not I'm gonna
cuz there gaps in thinking where you
make leaps because you're kind to
yourself that you don't realize you're
making but when you're forced to write
it down and this is why I tweet or when
you have to talk to somebody you have to
complete those gaps and make it a proper
logical chain and the mistake that I
made when I was young was you know I
always wanted to seem like the smartest
kid in the room you know like just like
you probably want to seem like the
funniest kid in the room or the toughest
kid in the room right we're all losers
starting out we want to be winners so we
picked the thing we're good at and we
double down on it so I always want to be
the smartest kid in the room so what did
I do
I read a lot of books I memorized a lot
of things and then whatever I hadn't
memorized is pre-google I made it up so
it sounded good okay pre-google after
google fact-checking started not a
better google improved me that way
exactly so now what I realized is that
the biggest mistake was memorization
right because when you're actually
trying to live your life
in congruence with reality you you want
to have a deep understanding of what you
do and why you do it and so it's much
more important to know the basics really
well there is to know the advanced
knowing calculus wouldn't help you today
it doesn't help you in business doesn't
help you in most things but knowing
arithmetic it really will help you
really whether it's at the corner
grocery store accounting change to
figuring out the value of your podcast
business to figuring out how to do the
probability math on you know some action
that you want to take so understanding
basic mathematics hold is way more
important than memorizing calculus
concepts and the problem is and this is
true of I think all reasoning it's much
better to know the basics from the
ground up solid foundation of
understanding a steel frame of
understanding that is to just have a
scaffolding we're just memorizing
advanced concepts this is why there are
a lot of people I'm sure that you listen
to who are really smart they use a lot
of jargon and you can't quite follow
their reasoning you don't know how
they're putting things together and
you're this deep down suspicion they
don't even really understand so if you
look at the the most powerful thinkers
especially the ones where money or life
is on the line they have to understand
the basics really really well Richard
Fineman the famous physicist was able to
he had this piece in one of his lectures
where he takes you from counting numbers
on your hand all the way to calculus in
four pages of text and that orally but
written down to four pages of text and
it's a complete unbroken logical chain
that takes you through geometry
trigonometry precalculus analytic
geometry graphs everything all the way
to calculus he understood numbers at a
core level he didn't have to memorize
anything when you're memorizing it's an
indication that you don't understand you
should be able to read arrive anything
on the spot and if you can't you don't
know it so do you apply that to things
other than mathematics everybody to
everything everything you don't even
make attempt to memorize things just
make an attempt to understand them you
can't help but memorize things right if
you can't and this is where Twitter is
great for me as I try to understand
something and then I try to write it
down in such a way that I can remember
it just the basic hook that will point
towards the deeper understanding and I'm
forced to explain it to people and
that's how I know I understand something
so this is what I meant originally we
talked about read
a good book I'll read one page in a
night and then I'm spend the rest of the
night thinking about it
or I'm chasing down references on
Wikipedia or weird blog post trying to
understand it mm-hmm
you know so for example there was a I
was dealing with this is a few months
back I was dealing with a question of
stupid topic but the meaning of life
right what's the meaning how could that
be stupid though well it's right it's
trite you're not supposed to think about
it it's something you ask your parents
when you're young they tell you don't
worry about it or they still get a job
yeah exactly good job you frickin hippie
or here's God God is the meaning of life
right and so I was just trying to
resolve for myself like what could the
answer be right not what is the answer
but what could the answer be and so at a
core level I was forced to kind of
hunting down all these weird little
things and really understand for myself
it's gotta be personal right but I'd
established for myself what it could and
could not be and that gave me some level
of peace so now I don't have to keep
asking that question what is the meaning
of life I mean you you I think the
question is more interesting than the
answer everyone should explore this on
their own but let me just explore a few
parts with you
right so first is if I gave you an
answer if I said the meaning of life is
to please God well which God okay
judeo-christian God well okay why that
one why this thing the problem is it's a
why question you can keep asking why
forever right any answer I give you you
just ask why again why again why don't
kid that's right and you end up in a
place called a grip astre lemma
okay this is a philosophical exercise
but I kind of thought it through then
googled around and there's a thing
called a grip astre lemma and a grip was
trilemma says that any questioning like
this the Y will always end in one of
three places okay first is infinite
regress right why because of this why
that what and just keep playing for
imminent the second is circular
reasoning
well a why a because it be or why be
because of a get trapped in that or the
third is an axiom and the most popular
axiom is God but it could be anything
because of math because the science
because of the Big Bang because the
simulation right these are all axioms
these are all just stopping points the
same simulation we're in a simulation or
saying it's
Big Bang is this another way of saying
god it's just God's a dirty word so I'm
gonna use it as much anymore but same
thing so you end up in one of these
three dead ends essentially right so
there is no answer
the real answer is because you get to
make up your own answers the beauty if
there was a single answer we would not
be free we would be trapped because then
we would all have to live to that answer
then we'd be Borg like robots each one
competing with each other to fulfill
that single meaning more than the others
back to signaling like I'm better at it
than you are but luckily there is no
answer so you just do whatever you want
the meaning of life it's funny that that
would let that's the basis of all
existential angst that you don't you
don't know why you're here
and you have this feeling that it could
be meaning less it is I mean if you when
you start pondering the the multiverse
the universe the galaxies the solar
system the planet the organism the cells
inside the organism the bacteria the
parasites okay there's symbiotic
relationship we have to our environment
and you start going Jesus Christ what am
I just a little piece of this thing it's
like well the answer is still all the
great questions are paradoxes yeah so
for example you're asking like do I
matter
that's like really the question you
asked right well how do i matter in this
infinite universe well you know on the
one hand you're separate no two points
are the same every point is every two
points are infinitely different you're
completely separated no one will have
your thoughts your emotions your
feelings your experience so your life is
a single-player game you're trapped
inside your head and you're just aware
of a bunch of things going on and that's
it on the other hand I cannot say the
words Joe Rogan without invoking the
entire universe Joe rogue alien comes
along says what's that Joe Rogan what's
Joe Rogan's a human what's a human
bipedal ape what's an ape on the earth
what's the earth planet
what's a planet solar system where was
the carbon made inside stars right
instead I have to create the entire
universe to just say the words Joe Rogan
so in that sense you're connected to
everything it's inseparable so the
answer to that question
do I matter is I am nothing and I am
everything and you'll find this with all
the great questions the answers are all
paradoxes which is why it's some level
it's sort of pointless to pursue them to
find a trite answer like I'm giving but
the act of pursuing them is actually
really useful because then it gives you
certain intrinsic understanding in your
life that brings a level of peace I feel
like there's with many people this
stress of this question is also
accentuated by unhappy lives son Saxon
accentuated by unhappy choices by being
trapped there's a big difference between
not knowing what the meaning of life is
and God I got to get the [ __ ] out of
this job I have to I can't live my life
this way what's the meaning of life if
this is my life which is why I always
start with let's get you rich first mmm
that's why I'm very practical about it
because look the you know Buddha was a
prince okay he started out really rich
and then he got to go off in the woods
and in the old days what happened was if
you wanted to be peaceful inside you
would become a monk you would renounce
everything you'd become an ascetic you
would give everything up you renounce
women men you'd renounce children you
renounce money he renounce politics
science technology everything and you
would go out in the woods by yourself
you to give everything up to be free
inside well today we have this wonderful
invention called money where you can
just store stuff up in a bank account
okay and you can basically save up you
can you can work really hard you can do
great things for society and Society
will give you money for giving it things
that it wants and it doesn't know how to
get and then you can save that up and
you can live well below with your means
and you can find a certain freedom in
that and that will give you the time and
the energy to pursue your own internal
peace and happiness so I believe the
solution to making everybody happy is to
give them what they want let's get them
all rich well let's get them all fit and
healthy and then let's get them all
happy is are those things even possible
can I really everyone can be written
everyone can be everyone here's my
thought exercise for now it seems like
we're in an infomercial everyone can my
home this is my rolls-royce yeah so
that's a good point so everything that
I've ever created on this topic of how
to make money I would never charge a
dollar for mmm because that would ruin
it
which show that I'm just another
huckster who's trying to get rich off of
you there are no get-rich-quick somebody
else trying to get rich off of you
right so it's so to me it's more of a
philosophical contribution we're for it
to have meeting and to be legit
I can't charge you anything for it but
yes everybody can be rich and let me
give you a thought exercise okay
imagine if tomorrow we could wave a wand
and everybody was trained as a scientist
or an engineer everybody even if you
weren't very good
you had enough understanding computers
you could write some code you could
build some hardware and don't tell me
people can't do it because they can
that's just a tyranny of soft
expectations that's just you looking
down on somebody else they can't do it
they just have to be educated now if
they're educated all this hardware
software engineers scientists biologists
technicians hard sciences and not the
social sciences we would all be done
within five years robots would be doing
everything from cleaning toilets to
cooking food to flying airplanes and
driving ubers and what would we be doing
we would be doing all creative jobs to
entertain each other and researching
science and technology we would have
wonderful lives so it is really just a
question of Education nothing else is
this a scale issue though I mean you're
talking about it as if this would work
with 300 million people it'll work with
10 billion people it'll work this is
base ferrying race with 100 trillion
people just we have the resources we
have the ability the universe is
infinite resources you build it you know
have you heard of a Dyson Sphere
mm-hmm you know you pull the Dyson
Sphere on a star and you gather all its
energy like that there's so much energy
out there one asteroid it's got all the
minerals that we need
one Sun one solar system has got all the
power we will need for a long long time
you know we can extract it of nuclear
fusion you know we're not that far from
those kinds of technologies working it's
just a question of guts and you know an
interest like we should be building
nuclear fusion test plants on the moon
the moon should be littered with no
downside right yeah if you could how
would that work well it is send a bunch
of people up there to work well the
problem robots
the problem with fission nuclear fission
is that you know nature creates energy
through nuclear energy right
like the Sun creates energy nuclear
energy now for transmission we use
photons because photons don't interact
and so photons are great for information
transmission but they're actually not
great for energy transmission for energy
creation you want nuclear to work and
the problem is because nuclear energy
you know we built it with a bomb we have
dirty nukes all those kinds of problems
with Fukushima Three Mile Island
Chernobyl we don't innovate anymore on
nukes imagine if when the first steam
engine blew up we said oh no more steam
engines for a while or very carefully
regulated billion dollars of regulation
you can't innovate that way when the
first airplane crashed we said no more
innovation in airplanes right so we need
a way to iterate on nuclear fission and
eventually fusion and get them working
safely cleanly passive it's a failure
etc if we're gonna find our way out of
the energy trap and the best place to do
that is someplace like in the Moon or
Mars do you think that's actually a
possibility that they could get nuclear
power to the point where it's not a
detriment because what everyone's
worried about is a meltdown right yeah
and we do have these old plants that are
running that are running on this this is
50-year old technology it's crazy
because there's no ability to shut them
off right very old technology they do
now have Gen 4 nuclear reactors that are
passive failsafe so in other words when
they fail they fail into us we pull the
plug on them they fail into a state
where there's no leakage there's no
problem their default is a positive
outcome as opposed to the current ones
the old ones where if you unplug them
like and these even these Gen 4 or just
gen 4 they're not Gen 5 1,800 where
we're microprocessors right and that
should be something that people are
working towards I hope so I mean on an
ideal world we would the problem is if
you have nuclear energy on the moon how
do you get it home right so what you
actually got to do is you've got a Revit
on the moon and you're using it there
maybe to launch more satellites more
rockets further out into the solar
system and that's the initial use case
but then eventually the technology gets
so good you can bring it home now I want
to go back to this idea of getting
people rich that somehow or another
that's gonna make people happy how do
you stop that the the natural
progression that people have of you know
oh
you know I have got a nice Chevrolet
yeah but I really want to BMW I've got a
nice BMW but now I want a Mercedes I
have mercy I want a Ferrari okay how do
you stop that material possession trap
because you can't at some level but I
think most smart people over time
realize that possessions don't make them
happy right it's just you have to go
through that you have to buy your stupid
car to realize that it doesn't attract
attractive girls that actually just
attracts other dudes who are like hey I
like that car man right like like you
have some expensive cars out there some
fancy cars tell me how you know how much
that attracts women versus men
well I marry those are for me I just
enjoy machines yeah so they me they're
toys that's a particular thing where you
enjoy machines but I think very as you
get older you just realize that there's
no happiness in material possessions now
lack of material possessions can make
you very unhappy yes so being poor can
make you unhappy but being rich is not
gonna make you happy
and what happens and fortunate a lot of
people struggle through their whole
lives to make money they make some
they're exhausted and then they're like
well now why am I not happy I guess I'm
just not a happy person and smart people
are unhappy that's like a great little
way to people feel better about it they
say well if you're smart you're not
happy right where's I positively the
other way if you're smart you should be
able to figure out how to be happy
otherwise no not that smart yeah that is
an offensive statement that if you're
smart you're not happy I've heard that
before and I just do not understand the
logic of that other than self justifying
I understand what it comes from it comes
from if you're smart it's usually
because you thought things through and
you're a very busy mind yeah and so busy
mind can often rob you of peace of mind
because well the peace that we seek is
not peace of mind it's peace from mind
right so if you look at all the crazy
activities you do to be happy right
whether it's like trying to get laid and
have an orgasm or you know extreme
sports or looking at something beautiful
or taking a psychedelic you're trying to
get out of your own pint you're trying
to get your monkey mind to stop
chattering at you for a moment you're
trying to get peace from the mind and
there are other better ways to do that
most of the ways we try to get peace
from mind are indirect
whereas if you understand things
if you see things properly you will
naturally slowly develop peace from mind
mmm sorry if I went on a tangent there
no it's a good tangent it's a good
tangent because I think often times the
pursuit is what's thrilling to people
and the possibility that one day they'll
be able to rest and that they'll reach
this goal that's the fundamental
delusion
that there is something out there that
will make me happy yes forever
yeah golden years there is it's called
death oh I'll take care of everything
that's the great leveler but when people
look at particularly social media which
bring back to that when you see someone
who you know you see them posed in front
of their mansion with their beautiful
car and they're leaning against it with
their designer clothes on their
expensive watch I want that that's what
I want what you really want is freedom
you want freedom for your money problems
right and I think that's okay so people
once someone can solve their money
problems either by lowering their
lifestyle or by making enough money and
you know essentially what you want to
get everybody to the retirement but not
retirement in the I'm 65 years old
sitting in a nursing home collecting a
cheque retirement different definition
retirement is when you stop sacrificing
today for some imaginary tomorrow hmm
yes when today is complete in and of
itself you're retired yeah and so how do
you get there well one is you can have
so much money saved up that just your
passive income off of that without your
having to lift a finger coverage your
burn rate keep your print rate low right
mm-hmm a second is you just drive your
burn rate down to zero you become a monk
a third is you're doing something you
love you enjoy it so much it's not about
the money right so there are multiple
ways to that path but the most common is
people just say I need to make more
money and the kind of wealth creation
that I talk about is about creating
timeless principles and adapting
yourselves that making money won't be an
issue and you can do it by doing what
you love right like we get into this
model of I must work for other people
work my way up the ladder nah I must
like do what that person is doing to
make money but really today in society
you get rewarded for creative
for creating something brand-new that
society didn't even know yet that it
wanted it doesn't know how to get other
than through you so the most powerful
moneymakers are actually individual
brands people like yourself or Elon or
Kanye or Oprah or Trump right these are
individual brands eponymous name brands
who themselves are leveraged like you're
leveraged you have broadcast media going
out to everybody that's leveraged the
podcast work for you and you sleep they
have knowledge that nobody else has
which is your knowledge is the knowledge
of being Joe Rogan I mean who else is a
UFC fighter and a commentator and a
podcaster and a comedian and you know
interested in all these things and those
all these people can't replace you so we
have to pay you what you're worth and
was I never fought in the UFC though oh
you did okay sorry or you know you
whatever you're you're you're involved
in that whole scene you just have a
unique set of skill sets so because of
this unique what I call specific
knowledge because of the accountability
that you have with your name because the
leverage that you have through your
media you're a money-making machine
I'm sure at this point I could make you
start over tomorrow wipe out your bank
account you'd be rich again in no time
because you have all the skill sets so
once people have those skill sets and
the beauty is the way you've done it is
you don't have any competition there's
no substitution if Joe Rogan were to
disappear off the air tomorrow it's not
like random podcast or number twelve
would step in and fill that thing no
it's it's just gone so the way to get
out of that competition trap is actually
to be authentic the winner in hire is
actually to find the thing that you know
how to do better than anybody and you
know how to do that better any because
you love to do it no one can compete
with you if you love to do it be
authentic and then figure out how to map
that to what society actually wants
apply some leverage put your name on it
so you take the risks but you gain the
rewards have ownership and equity in
what you do and then just crank it out I
think people have to be very careful to
not get trapped along the way with
things that you can afford with your
current lifestyle like the way you're
living and the way you're earning but
they're also imprisoning you and the
fact that you are now going to have to
work this 40 hour week job in order to
get this thing that you can't afford but
now you're saddled down to this job
you've not you're not saving your
you're not putting things in a good
place and you're working for these
things working for things as rewards is
a real trap that a lot of people fall
into it's the biggest one let's even
tell EV also says that there are two
great addictions heroin and a monthly
salary and and that's why you can't get
rich writing out your time because you
know when you start charging more and
more for your time it's a slow upgrade
loop and then you upgrade your house at
the same time like your car at the same
time you move in the neighborhood you
really also have to get used to ignoring
your peers or upgrading or changing the
definition of your peers a lot of people
here who are poor here but they would be
rich if they were living in Thailand in
Bali and if they have the luxury of a
remotely doable job they may want to be
living there and saving up money but the
ignoring the peers is an issue because
the keeping up with the Joneses is a
real phenomenon
yeah envy makes the world go around yeah
and then there's this other thing that
people have to avoid even allowing their
mind to think when they're hearing what
you're saying and you know all this
logical fantastic advice there's these
six dirty words that's easy for you to
say yeah that is a terrible trap and
look I grew up as a first generation
immigrant in Jamaica Queens with zero
money single mom two kids working day
and I'd go to school you know I washed
dishes I was Kate I wasn't working
catering jobs I was mowing lawns
I was working since the age of 11 on and
off here and there didn't have two cents
to rub together you know I had to borrow
400 ollars to go to college like
literally a short $4 400 I had to find
$400 I'm gonna have it you know got
rejected from a job at Dunkin Donuts so
like okay it's not to say that it's easy
it's not easy she's actually really
freaking hard it is the hardest thing
you will do but it's also the rewarding
thing you know look at the kids who are
born rich no meaning to their lives
you're terrible place yeah you're real
you're real resume is just a cataloging
of all your suffering okay if I were to
ask you to describe your real life to
yourself and you look back and
deathbed you're gonna go back and say
what are the interesting things I've
done and it's all gonna be around the
sacrifices that you made and the hard
things that you did anything you're
given doesn't matter you know you have
your four limbs you have your brain you
have your head you have your skin that's
all for granted so you have to do hard
things anyway to create your own meaning
in life making money is a fine one ya
struggle it is hard I'm not gonna say
it's easy it's a really hard but the
tools are all available it's all there
there's also these traps that people
sort of establish in their own mind of
giving themselves excuses or giving
themselves in unsurmountable obstacles
insurmountable drinkin mentality yeah
somebody else's fault that's my mother's
fault it's the system's fault yeah those
people are sinking I feel bad for them I
want to shake them out of it and say
actually you can get out of it you just
have to stop thinking it's everybody so
all to the perspective yeah it's so
difficult for people to do it's one of
the most difficult things for people to
do is to change the way they approach
approach reality itself at the end of
the day I do think even despite what I
said earlier life is really a
single-player game it's all going on in
your head you know whatever you think
you believe will very much shape your
reality both from what risks you take
and what actions you perform but also
just everyday experience of reality if
you're walking down the street and
you're judging everyone you're like I
don't like that person because their
skin color I don't like that oh she's
she's not attractive that guy's fat this
person is a loser oh who put this in my
way you know the more you judge the more
you're gonna separate yourself and
you'll feel good for an instant because
you'll feel good about yourself I'm
better than that but then you're gonna
feel lonely and then you're just gonna
see negativity everywhere the world just
reflects your own feelings back at you
reality is neutral reality has no
judgments to a tree there's no concept
of right or wrong or good or bad right
you're born you give a whole set of
sensory experiences and stimulations and
lights and colors and sounds and then
you die
yeah and how you choose to interpret
that is up to you you do have that
choice so this is what I meant that
happiness is a choice if you believe
it's the choice then you can start
working on it and I can't tell you how
to find it because use your own
conditionings that are making you
happy so you have to uncondition
yourself it's just like I can't fix your
eating habits for you can give some
general guidelines but you gotta go
through the hard habit forming of how to
eat right but you have to believe it's
possible and it is absolutely possible I
was miserable I'm happy as a clam and
it's not just the money I got there
before the money you got happy before
the money mostly yeah how did you get
happy before the money I started getting
older you know I just realized like life
is short I'm gonna die
again try right right in many ways yeah
well Confucius had a great saying that
you know every man has two lives and the
second starts when he realizes he has
just one Wow and I read that it was one
of those book dropping lines you know
it's like mic drop Confucius had a lot
of mic drops that's a crazy one that was
a great one or another one is next time
you get sick you know because everybody
gets sick every now and then it's like a
happy person once ten thousand things a
sick person just wants one thing right
so it's your it's your unlimited desires
or clouding your peace your happiness
have desires
you're a biological creature that stands
up and says I can do something I I move
I resist I live but just be very careful
of your desires this is the oldest most
trite wisdom desire is suffering that's
what it means right every desire you
have is an access where you will suffer
so just don't focus on more than one
desire at a time the universe is rigged
in such a way that if you just want one
thing and you focus on that you'll get
it but everything else you gotta let go
did you make a gradual shift to
happiness or was it a radical change
it's ongoing its gradual every day
you're happier today than you were a
month ago yeah allegedly yeah yeah I'm
very happy these days deliriously so
it's actually hard for me to hang out
with normal people oh really so you
you've made a significant shift over the
period of like how many years about
eight years eight years yeah Wow and is
this something that you've pursued
through certain books or is it just like
you you've made an understanding or
gained an understanding in your own mind
and then started pursuing it based on I
understand
yeah it's very very personal it's
basically you have to decide as a
priority and then I tried every hack I
possibly could I used to you know I
tried all the I tried meditation I tried
witnessing you know I even tried missus
RI just to see what it would feel like
how did it feel it was it turned me from
a pessimist to an optimist but I didn't
like the physical side effects nor did I
want to be in a drug for a sustained
basis mm so I dropped it and I thought
it'd turn you into an optimist yes at
the time I used to be a pessimist yeah I
started doing things like I would start
looking at the you know in every moment
and everything that happens you can look
on the bright side of something right
and so I used to do that forcibly and
then I trained it until I became second
nature so for example like a friend of
my wife's was over and she when we were
dating and she took all these photos she
took like hundreds of photos and then
she sends them all to us
and my immediate reaction was like why
are you dumping hundreds of photos on my
phone I don't need hundreds of photos
have some judgment that's my immediate
reaction and then I could say actually
how nice of her she sent me hundreds of
photos I can pick the one that I like
right there are two ways of seeing
almost everything there are a few things
that are like high suffering so you
can't do that other than just saying
well this is a teacher right but I
slowly work through every negative
judgement that I had until I saw the
positive and not second nature to me I
also realized that like what you want is
you want to clear minds you want to let
go of thoughts happy thoughts disappear
out ahead automatically very easy to let
go of them negative thoughts linger so
if you interpret the negative the
positive and everything very quickly you
let it go right you let it go much
faster okay simple hacks get more
sunlight right learn to smile more learn
to hug more these things actually
released serotonin in Reverse they
aren't just outward signals of being
happy they're actually feedback loops to
being happy spend more time in nature
you know these are obvious watch your
mind watch your mind all day long watch
what it does not judge it and I try to
control it but you can meditate 24/7
meditation is not a sit down close your
eyes activity meditation is just
basically watching your own thoughts
like you would watch anything else in
the outside world and say why am I
having that thought does that serve me
anymore is that conditioning from when I
was ten years old like for example I'm
getting ready for this podcast
you got ready I didn't all right good I
did but I did but I did I couldn't help
it and what happened was the few days
leading up to this my mind was just
running and normally my mind is pretty
calm it was just running and running and
running and every thought I would have
I would imagine me saying it to you my
brain couldn't help but rehearse what
what is doing is just rehearsing all the
time to talk to you and then I was even
rehearsing rehearsed telling you about
the rehearsal mmm all play better games
and I was just like shut up stop it what
is going on and it took me a while to
figure out oh yeah you know what it is
when I was a kid in Queens and I had no
money and I had nothing and I needed to
save myself the way I got out was by
sounding smart not being smart sounding
smart that was the skill I perfected so
I am hardwired to always rehearse things
so I will sound smart it's a disease it
keeps me from being happy so but when
you see that when you realize that when
you understand something then it
naturally calms you down so after that I
stopped rehearsing as much Wow but it
still a trained habit that is a really
interesting point that you want to sound
smart that that many people do that and
especially young people when you see
someone who is smart or someone who
appears smart they say smart things you
kind of want to sound smart I want
people to think about me the same way I
think about that person that is my
disease that isn't my feeling is what
clutters my mind I the the thing I have
to ask myself now is if I can would I
still be interested in learning this
thing if I couldn't ever tell anybody
about it that's how I know it's real
that's how I know it's something I
actually want that's a common thing
though I know I suffered from that when
I was young the desire to sound smart
that's it's very it's very common well
all of us start out you know every
everything you're the winner now in your
life you were to loot you it's because
you were a loser at some point right if
if you had gotten all the girls if you
had all the money if you had everything
you want you were good-looking and in
junior high or high school you wouldn't
have done anything with your life
and you would have peaked early it's
like the Bruce Springsteen glory days
song right you're the married your high
school sweetheart you'd be living in
your hometown you know you'd be a
manager at the local McDonald's whatever
the first dream job you had thank God we
didn't all get what we wanted when we
were young right or we would be trapped
in that so you have to be able to break
out of where you came from I don't know
where I was going that is interesting to
about people who peak too early yeah or
maybe those people that peak too early
can do the Elan Mustang and just abandon
it and start something new and then
learn the the the joys of sucking at
something yeah and actually though in
our professions especially when you're
high visibility
the problem with peaking is that you
then get drowned in in death of a
thousand cuts people have expectations
of you Hey Joe can you come to my event
hey Joe can you look at my business plan
hey Joe can give me advice on this can
you you know talk to my friend can you
come in this podcast you're just being
assaulted all the time with inbound
opportunities so you have no time to
start over with anything so you have to
ruthlessly ruthlessly disappoint
everybody eliminate and clear your
schedule drop all the meetings not even
respond to the emails the only way
you're gonna be able to start over with
anything yeah and I we talked about this
that I'd love your approach to meetings
if they not meaning life or death I've
the same way I avoided a good one
recently and this was someone that was
just tracking me down as a high profile
person in a big organization and I'm
like can we just talk on the phone then
we talked to the phone list there was
nothing to say it was just they wanted
to get me in the office and yeah and
meeting somebody phone calls phone call
should be emails and yeah just be text
right with meetings I I mean I I despise
meetings I used to own the domain I
don't do coffee calm I eventually though
I used to respond from the vault I don't
do coffee you know that's a little bit
of a jerk move but really where it comes
from is when I was young one of my
principles was I knew I had to make
money it was my overwhelming desire and
one of the things I did was I said okay
I'm never gonna be worth more than what
I think I'm worth okay no one's gonna
pay me more than what I think I'm worth
so what am i worth so I picked an hourly
rate for myself that I was worth and I
said I'm never gonna squander my time
less than this so if original is 500
bucks an hour then I upgrade to 5000
bucks an hour it's ludicrous but pick an
aspirational hourly rate aspirational
has to be a little ludicrous and then
what I would do is if I have to return
something I'm standing in line to return
something it's below my hourly rate I'll
throw it away if I have to if I or give
it away if I have to do some tasks and I
can hire somebody to do it for less than
my hourly rate I would hire them and so
I just became extremely jealous of my
time which doesn't mean you can't have
fun rest leisure spending time with your
friends and family that's all great
don't count that but if you're doing
anything you don't want to do which is
the definition of work it's a set of
things that you have to do that you
don't want to do if you're working it
better be for your hourly rate otherwise
don't do the work and so once it came
out of that then I just cause 2 meetings
a cost of meetings is so high especially
given all the people who are in there
right one person is talking seven people
listening you're literally just dying an
hour at a time so you have to just drop
non urgent meetings or figure out to be
more efficient with them if you're gonna
do anything great the extreme example is
business travel getting on a plane to
fly halfway around the world for one
meeting which never amounts to anything
and then like wasting your whole little
life there and then flying back so about
five years ago I resolved I am never
going to travel for business Wow and I
haven't travel for business since I only
travel if the travel experience will be
so entertaining and joyous because I
have friends or the place I want to see
or whatever that it will be complete in
and of itself because I know that
whatever the business meeting it came
from it isn't is never worth it
Wow and actually that principle applies
larger than just travel it applies to
life in general the this one of the
secrets to happiness is to really
embrace what you're doing in that moment
that's trite but where that where that
comes from is saying I only want to do
actions that are complete in and of
themselves right if I'm looking for some
ulterior motive down the line it's not
gonna materialize and and if you think
it is maybe even if it does it'll be
very short-lived anything you want in
your life whether it's a car or whether
it was a girl or there's money when you
got it a
your litter you were back to zero your
brain had hedonic Lee adapted to it and
you were looking for the next thing
that's a great statement hedonic Lee
adapted that's that is what happens to
people you get accustomed to whatever it
is I realized that when I first got a
new apartment it was a nice apartment
and after a while I'll get used to it
was like oh okay it's just an apartment
it's just where I live I'm used to it's
nice but I'm used to it yeah we all go
through this learning it's it's you know
it's riding the ferris wheel of life
it's like you get at the bottom like I
want to get to the top that's so
exciting you ride it up you get a little
dopamine rush and get a little serotonin
then you ride it back down as that wears
off now you need another high then you
ride it back up and write it back down
in fact the more highs you get the
harder it gets to go around the wheel
and more bored you get a bit in the
harder it goes to go back up so what
lights your fire now like what what gets
you motivated to do things and to act
art art this is art oh okay
art is this creativity it's just
anything that's done for its own sake
so what are the things that are done for
their own sake there's nothing beyond
loving somebody creating something
playing art to me creating businesses
play I create businesses early stage
because it's fun because I I'm into the
product even when I invest it's because
I like the people I like hanging out
with them I learn from them and I think
the product is really cool so these days
I will pass on all kinds of great
investments because I'm like I just the
products not interesting it's boring I'm
not going to learn anything that's a
beautiful luxury it is a luxury art and
learning yeah it is a luxury these are
not 100 percent or zero things right you
can in your life start moving more and
more towards that but that's a goal it's
a goal
when I was younger I used to be so
desperate to make money that I wouldn't
done anything right if you'd shown up
and said hey I got a sewage trucking
business and you're gonna go into that I
said great let's do it I'm gonna make
money thank God no one gave me that
opportunity I'm glad that it went down
the road of Technology and science which
I genuinely enjoy mmm and so I got to
the combine my vocation and my avocation
I mean what do you do you're playing
you're having fun you're doing art
you're not you're not working no that's
what I always say when people say we're
Cardon likes order not really I'm always
working but it looks like work to them
but it feels like play to me and that's
how I know no one can compete with me on
it because I'm just playing 16 hours a
day and if they want to compete with me
and they're gonna work they're gonna
lose because they're not going to do it
16 hours a day seven days a week
listen man there are some gems of wisdom
in this conversation and that I hope
people pull things out of this and apply
them to their own life and I'm certainly
going to listen to you again and and and
try to apply some of this to my own life
stuff that I'm not already applying but
I really appreciate your time and I
really appreciate you coming in here
thanks for having and please tell people
you do a small little podcast is just
the navall podcast right yeah best way
to find me is like Twitter actually okay
just at navall then I have a website at
nav al I have a youtube channel in the
fall and I have a podcast in the well
that's it well thank you very much thank
you I really appreciate it thank you bye
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]